[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the podcast
another hotly hotly anticipated
edition of roll on slash roll call we're
still
in a no man's land we are going to call
this i guess it's roll on
it's wrong but roll roll call is good
yes
it's been a minute since we've been here
i think it's been a month one month
since i sat down with you a lot has
happened during that period of time
we're going to unpack
all of it but just to reintroduce you
in the event that there are new
listeners and watchers to the show i'm
sitting across from my friend adam
skolnik
journalist at large adventurer
environmentalist
author co-author of the great david
goggins book can't hurt me
new york times uh contributor
among many other things swim run
aficionado
swim run is like probably the most
recurring theme
on this podcast as of late we're going
to talk a little bit about that today
even more brief overview basically what
we do
in this special version of the podcast
is talk about what we
call the big story we pick one thing
from the news or something that piques
our interest we dive deep into it
we have a teachable moment we do a
little show and tell and then in the
second half
of the show we take a couple listener
questions
you can leave your question if you would
like it addressed on our facebook group
or you can leave us a voicemail which is
most preferred at 424-235-4626 and we
will air it on the show
and discuss the main reason why
we missed our last bi-weekly edition of
roll on
is uh because the man sitting across
from me had
kind of a life-changing event that
occurred that prevented him from being
here
and then we had to scramble to get
another episode up
in time uh it was predictable of course
sorry about that tell us what happened
uh my wife gave birth to our son oh my
goodness
zuma came came to us on
august 29th at 6 11 in the p.m
and it was uh yeah man it was an
incredible day it started early in the
morning
she started getting contractions and we
had like the full
um yoga spirituality mantra is kind of
blaring in the
office in our uh we have a two bedroom
and so in the office
slash maybe future baby room uh-huh and
uh
and she was super in charge of the
energy there was so much energy flowing
and then
by the by eight o'clock that night we
were in the hospital
and then it was a full almost 24 hours
later she was in labor for 38 hours
um 38 yeah with that we uh that
zuma came in once she started pushing it
was like just over an hour
the doctors were like whoa that's very
fast because one to three hours
and um and he was you know
almost eight pounds and healthy and and
then we had nurses for a couple of days
in the hospital and
and by the way the team at ucla at the
labor and delivery ucla santa monica is
incredible just incredible doctors
incredible nurses and then after two
days they send you home
and you have to figure out figure out
what to do it's that thing it's like
wait wait you're not coming with me yeah
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait where did these ghosts
go what do we do now
when's somebody gonna come and pick this
thing up you know
exactly yeah and uh and meanwhile your
wife is just torn up and like
you know emotional and just like
everything is going haywire in her body
which is completely ill-equipped and
you're really equipped but you have to
step up
like like into the breach and so it was
cool you know like the first day
the first night um
you know i'd always i'd thought of
people who've like done co-sleeping and
slept in the bed with their babies i
always thought that seems hazardous but
on that first night the only thing that
soothed him
was being on on one of our chests and so
i had him on my chest on the couch and
he fell asleep and i just brought him to
bed
and literally had him like in the nook
on my arm
sleeping with him that way on night one
now we have a better sleeping system but
like that first night
right away you're breaking all your
rules you know you're just trying to
figure it out yeah but there's something
profound that happens
there and in reality he's like a super
chill baby and
and um not he you know he doesn't like
uh
being in poopy pants or having his
diaper change so there's an irony there
yeah
well who does right who who wants that
and uh so other than that he's like
really chill and he's and he's doing
great and
uh mom is doing great she's bounced
right back and and
everything's going well i'm i'm knocking
on wood it's been cool
are you one of those guys who always
wanted to be a dad
or were you on the fence about that
no i mean it's uh it's both you know
growing up i always assumed i'd be a dad
i loved kids i was one of those people
like
as a teenager and in college and you
know as a young adult
gravitated towards that i was in
education for a hot minute and
um love hanging out with little kids and
always had a good time with it so i just
assumed it was gonna happen
um then after my divorce i was married
once before
uh when i was 40 i'd we were divorced 41
i think i was divorced
uh you know i just thought it wouldn't
happen i just assumed okay
well now you know when i remarry if i
remarry probably someone a little older
and it probably just won't happen and so
i just assumed that or maybe i'd be a
stepdad or something like that
you know that was kind of the assumption
i had yeah and um and then
and when april and i got together we we
still didn't have plans to have kids we
weren't like necessarily trying
um and so so then when it happened you
know we embraced it
uh but no i didn't think by the time
like we got married and and
you know this time last year i did not
think i would be a father
yeah did you have that experience of
instant
love it's interesting you hear about
like the instant like for me
i'm just not i mean i think i don't i i
take it like i don't think i'm like that
like people think
they talk about these really high
moments for me the high moments tend to
be not the things people think about
um i didn't have this all of a sudden
shaktipod like
heartbursting my life is totally
different experience
um not to say that i don't love my son
or i
have enjoyed the experience but it
didn't didn't realign
everything for me right away but i will
say this last week and we'll talk about
it in a little bit
this story came my way and i just
couldn't resist getting back in after
just one week off and
doing a little bit of writing um and uh
and i'll
i'll tell you guys why but that
experience like
doing a story used to always be like i'd
be so hyped up on it
and i'd be like i'd need to get every
interview and if i didn't have it coming
i'd
i'd have all sorts of anxiety when will
i get it or or
when will the editor read it all that's
gone and i don't know if it's sleep
deprivation
or just like more chill about things
because
you know i have something way more
important in my life like i have no
anxiety
about that at all right you know
reassignment of priorities so that's
what's really important yeah so i think
that's the most profound thing i've
noticed so far
and i do feel like the love the love is
there it's not like it's not there
and i think as i as i grow into this
uh new phase i'll probably see more of
those kinds of more subtle realignments
and it'll grow into something huge two
points that i want to make
first the most important point is that i
was the only one who called the day
yes you called the day i forgot yes he
did
august 29th let's make that known for
the record
yes i thought it was going to be at 2 30
in the morning
yeah but you thought it was saturday
night but 2 30 in the morning right yeah
yeah yeah yeah second thing is uh
zuma i mean it's the most epic name of
all time
also very california it is very it is
well so explain
okay so it's zuma james kahlu skolnik is
his name
zuma um it means abundance in chumash
uh it's and chumash is the native uh
indigenous tribe of this region yes and
we
spent most of our recreation time off
point doom diving a reef out there and
point doom was
sacred in the chumash culture and so and
zuma is the beach
and zuma is the beach right there so uh
so that was april's decision she wanted
to be zuma
and originally she was throwing out
aspen and i'm like i like aspen trees
but we're not really ever in aspen
or around aspen trees so she came up
with zuma which i think
fits better plus i have a nephew and
niece zach and zoe
so it like adds to the z's in the family
alliterative
so it's nice um and then james
uh in the jewish tradition we sometimes
take the first
letter of someone's name that you want
to name your child after we don't
usually do the like the
you know adam skullnick jr type stuff
but you might take someone's first
initial and and honor someone with that
and so i had an uncle jay michaelson
who growing up meant uh you know we
spent a lot of time with
he and uh my aunt sid and and
three cousins uh john jeremy and jenny
and we spent a lot of time together like
a lot of road trips all the first travel
experience of my life were with them
and he just meant a lot to me growing up
and into young adulthood
and he died uh younger than you're
supposed to in his 60s
and and so i wanted to honor him so
james j for jay michaelson and then kalu
for ekalu who is uh who died
last year freedom fighter in uh karin
state burma
area and he's exiled a freedom fighter
who became basically
ran his country's health system
from exile in mesa thailand uh like
you've heard about the rohingya who were
you know massacred and abused by the
myanmar
military for years that's happened in
all sorts of ethnic states
in burma which is this country with a
lot of different
ethnicities the korean people are one of
those uh
uh states that was uh under continual
attack for
you know decades and echolou is helping
to kind of keep a medical system in
place
even though all these people are getting
displaced so he would train medics and
bring medics to displaced people camps
all over
uh korean state and he was just a gentle
giving incredible uh you know peaceful
warrior
right and he you interviewed him or you
did a story on that so i did a story on
um on that on on how
some american doctors were working with
ekolu and his team of medics
in um current state in the displaced
people's camps to
uh try to cut down on malaria because
malaria is killing a lot of people once
you're displaced
a lot of times what ends up killing
people in burma after the military burns
down your villages
you have nowhere to go and you're out
exposed and you can die of malaria
that's the
number one killer um and so uh
you know he they had come up with this
rapid malaria test
that was enabling some really early
interventions and cutting down on
malaria deaths and
it was able to be they did studies that
was able to be replicated in other
places that weren't necessarily war
zones
and so it's really important work that
they were doing like actually public
health work but doing it in
like in this really high intensity uh
war zone
type area and so yes i was out there i
basically uprooted my life and moved to
masat for months
and reported on this story um and
echoloe was like you know my number one
source and
and i featured him in the story and just
stayed close with him
uh and you know always remember him so
it's also because my wife is asian she's
from
uh she's from australia but her family
is her roots are malaysia southeast asia
as well
so it's a good way to honor uh our son's
asian heritage even though it's not
malaysian but it's still southeast asian
heritage
um so it's a good way to put a little of
that in there too a lot of
thought and intentionality yeah into
this name yeah
zuma james callow schoolnet that's it
wow yeah man so with that
having a newborn in the house how's the
uh
how's the fitness how's the training
guys the swimmer on training
not just all out the window right yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah just forget about it
barely any sleep he's been he's been
um pretty chill with sleep but he's
still you still have to attend to him
you wake up you know
your sleep is you're lucky if you get
you know six hours of sleep right um
six hours is great yeah six hours is
great i've been in insomniac for years
so i'm kind of built for it in a way
like broken sleep has been my thing for
so long
that it doesn't but i still need at
least like seven hours to feel good
um and we've been able to get we're
building up to that
um but i've done two three mile runs
basically right and
that's all i've done and that they were
all in the last four days so
so uh i haven't done a lot i hope to do
more i hope to get in the ocean
soon and just get a swim in but um what
do you think
what are my prospects here i think you
grab what you can
you know this is a really precious time
you want to be as present
as you possibly can for it and
with that realignment and priorities
your focus is on your newborn and in
supporting your wife yeah so uh so it's
natural and appropriate that your
fitness regimen is going to get
short shrift but you still have to carve
out
some time for yourself because as the
adage goes
if you're not taking care of yourself
you can't take care of others right so
you still have to
make sure that you have at least a
little bit of time that's just for you
so that you can recharge your battery
and then show up with the best of your
abilities to
you know support what's going on at home
that's it man i got to save out the dad
bod
hmm yeah no dad boss allowed a podcast
studio
i'll lose this job you're going to get
fired
um yeah well that's good i mean i i'll
check in with my
sort of latest on the fitness front um
when we last spoke i told you that
i was shifting my focus away from
endurance and on to strength
taking that 90 10 kind of 90
endurance 10 strength flipping it to
90 strength 10 endurance and i've
adhered to that
routine and i've been doing it now for i
don't know five weeks at this really
and it's been great you know i will say
that i'm not
a gym rat by nature when i wake up in
the morning and it's a nice day
i just want to go out on the trails
right and i just want to be
wild and free for a couple hours of just
running and
being in nature and the idea of being
you know
throwing some weight around inside a
building just is not appealing and for
many many years i just
shrugged it off i was like i'm not doing
that and i found myself
you know at 53 coming quickly upon 54
with some back issues and some
imbalances and just not feeling
strong you know i've gone through
periods of my life where i was very
strong
but this sort of over prioritization of
endurance training
um and not really taking the time or
carving out the time to
pay attention to functional strength and
making sure that overall my body is
sound has taken its toll
and like i mentioned i've had i'm having
some sciatica stuff some back problems
and just feeling
you know janky and not in command of my
corpus in the way that i would like so i
was like now is the time where
there's no rate there's nothing to be
trained for at the minute so
let me do the things that i'm always you
know telling myself i don't have time
for
and you know i started really slow
and was you know appalled at how weak i
was
in the gym and i should say just so
people know there's a little gym near my
house
that's part of the pool where i swim and
they
moved some of their gym equipment out of
the gym and into an outdoor space
okay and you can book one hour inc
you know one hour appointments so you
can only go in for one hour and they
restrict how many people can be in there
and you're wearing a mask so they've
under they can certainly safety in this
outdoor area
yeah it's like it's not a big space and
there's only like four people there when
i'm there
but the one hour window forces me to go
in and get it done
and not like you know kind of walk
around yeah do the kind of things that
you would do at the gym where you're
there for hours and you didn't really do
anything so it makes keep going
up keep the heart rate up you know get
through the workouts
and i'm doing really basic stuff like
bench press
and like squats and like you know just
stuff that ordinarily i just would never
do
yeah um and like i said you know started
off
with really lightweights in an almost
embarrassing fashion
uh which was a nice lesson in humility
and also
a dose of just how far away i'd moved
from that aspect of
being a physically fit athlete but i've
shown up for it
almost every day and now it's kicked in
and i'm starting to
see the gains and see the progression
and i feel
good in my body and i have one of those
physiques where you know if i touch a
weight like i blow up like
you know i can make gains pretty quickly
and
and i'm already seeing my body change
like i'm getting like wider and
like water like i'm used to in endurance
training it's all about power to weight
ratio
you want to be as lean as possible
without sacrificing power on the bike or
in the run
like the lighter you are right in
general the better you are you can get
too light
and then you're weak but it's finding
that perfect um
balance between those two things so
you're paying a lot of attention to
getting and so when you're riding your
bike and running all the time your upper
body just
the upper body yeah you know you start
to look like a you know like a 13 year
old boy after a while like if you look
at the tour de france riders and they
take their shirt off you're like holy
smokes
right but their legs are their legs are
massive they're like greek gods but
they're
so lean you know they're so light their
chassis are like you know just
reduced down to the barest minimum and
now i'm trying to build that back
up and it's been interesting but now i'm
at a place where
i've gotten over the hump of that
initial phase where
you know i feel like i'm embarrassed to
even be there
and now i have like some momentum and
i'm seeing some gains
and i'm looking forward to it in a way
that i wouldn't have predicted and i'm
really enjoying it
are you working with a trainer there no
i mean you know i know what to do
in the gym so that's been really fun
so no spotter on the bench press or
anything no but i'm not like i do
lower weight higher rep stuff but i'll
do like three rounds
per exercise and i break it down into
like one day i'll do
chest and arms the next day i do back
and shoulders and then i do legs and i
kind of rotate through that and it's a
really
basic rudimentary i'm not doing anything
you know funky or weird i'm not throwing
around kettlebells yet like i'm still
just trying to get
fundamentally like strong enough so then
i can start to challenge myself with
different and newer exercises at the
same time doing a ton of core stuff like
trying to
strengthen my back and strengthen you
know my abdominals
at the same time what i left off what i
left out
in the last time we spoke was the other
aspect of what i'm focusing on right now
which is
trying to re-learn running to rewild my
running
uh to quote the great tony riddle yes
was a
fantastic guest on the podcast he's all
about barefoot running and functional
strength
and getting back to kind of an ancestral
biomechanic relationship with the body
and with nature
and in the course of my day that i spent
with tony when he came out to do the
podcast
we went out well the first thing he did
when he arrived is
he started showing me all these drills
for barefoot running and we made a video
allie's right over here she
she created a really cool video that
people really enjoyed yeah
of us doing some drills and him taking
me through
a couple really basic routines
to retrain how to run and like you know
i've
i just go out and run like i haven't
really thought that much about technique
in a very long time and this is a very
counter-intuitive approach
to what is fundamentally you know
natural for everybody
but in those videos you didn't seem like
it didn't seem for you
actually when watching those videos yeah
well i was like what am i doing
here he's running barefoot on my gravel
driveway and i couldn't even walk on it
i was like how do you what are you even
doing like how is it even possible that
you could run
on these rocks yeah and not hurt your
feet like it was amazing
right yeah and it just seemed so foreign
and impossible to me
um i'm not there yet i will say that um
but
after we did those drills then we went
out to malibu creek state park and we
went running
and in allegiance to you know what he
was teaching me i pulled out
my pair of vivo barefoot running shoes
which i had not worn in quite some time
he did the whole thing barefoot i did
them in my vivos
and i couldn't walk for like a week
after what was
essentially a pretty easy six or seven
mile run because my calves were so sore
which was an indication of the fact that
this is a very different kind of motion
than what i was used to
and i was just amazed at his ability to
do this trail run barefoot like you know
like on little rocks and all kinds of
things that you would think would just
tear your feet apart but he's so
accustomed to this that he could do it
in an extremely graceful way
because his feet have a musculature that
ours don't right yeah yeah well it's
also this technique
of lifting like if you watch that video
or you
go to and take his programs he's got all
these online programs
it's all about like this light touch
with the earth where you're focusing on
on pulling your heels up and kicking
them back and working your
hamstrings and this leaning forward
motion it's a whole thing
that's very different from how you're
running in running shoes
and what i realized initially even when
i did that run with tony
was just how hard i was landing like you
know when you're wearing
a a minimal shoe you can feel the
pounding you know and you're
i'm like i have like a lead foot and
what is the relationship to that
the biometrics of that on the back pain
that i'm experiencing
or you know the occasional pain in my
hips that i'm feeling
what if i could relearn how to run so
that i have a very soft touch
and it's not a pounding experience but a
more um
human and natural approach to this
movement
right so i devoted myself to trying to
learn this
and this is a very i'm very much just in
the starting gate of trying to figure
this out
to retrain you know this process of
running and so
um i don't know what happened to those
vivo barefoot shoes i couldn't find them
so i went out and bought i bought
another pair and
i haven't worn anything but we're gonna
do a show and tell and i'm wearing them
right now because i just came from the
gym but i'll
in the show-and-tell i'll pull them out
and show you guys and we could talk a
little bit more about it
but it's been really interesting and
i've started this is another thing that
i started really slow just doing the
drills
being very gentle on myself not
overdoing it
and then went from drills to doing a run
like i ran 10 minutes you know just
trying to keep my cadence really high
focusing on lifting my
feet up being gentle on the earth not
pounding not landing hard
where were you running so just on unlike
there's
on i alternated between trails and
pavement because i i wanted i
i wanted to mix those two things up in
the vivos or barefoot
no in the vivo yeah yeah i'm not like
running barefoot yeah
okay yeah so i'm just trying to do this
i don't want to get injured either and
you know when i when my calves you know
were hurting for a week when i did when
i overstepped it and went out running
you know full
stop in these things i realized like
this is something that you know i could
easily get
hurt doing if i don't take it slowly so
yeah it started off with like a 10
minute run
now i'm up to being able to run an hour
in them and
i have no soreness and you know my
technique is coming along i still have a
lot to learn but
i'm getting better at it and it's been
really fun and this is
an example of looking for the
opportunity
in the quarantine like okay all these
things that i like to do
they're kind of off the table what can i
do that ordinarily
i wouldn't be able to justify or i would
just have a hard time wrapping my head
around it's like the world has stopped
like let's learn this thing let's take
the time
be patient and try to master
a new skill so it's been really fun and
i love it
i think also like you can't um understa
overstate the uh what that does to your
brain just learning just starting again
at
zero and being the beginning like the
beginner mind like what that does for
you
how that kind of keeps you young to some
degree and just keeps you
humble and all sorts of good things come
from being
open to being the beginner again it also
changes your relationship with time
when you're in a rut and in a routine
and doing things the way that you
always do them and always kind of
doubling down on your strengths and
ignoring your weaknesses
time especially as you get older seems
to speed up it's like wow it's already
september like what happened to the
summer yeah but when you
decide to try to learn something new
time slows down
and it seems more technicolor than it
would
ordinarily because it's triggering you
know it would be interesting to hear
what what andrew huberman would have to
say
about that because i think it lights up
other areas of your brain that are that
are dormant that's what i'm thinking i'm
like what kind of like
brain health thing is there from like
taking up something new they talk about
all the time with older people
learning a new language or you know like
you know yeah i wonder
there's got to be some sort of brain
health benefits sure there is
an overlooked aspect of well-being and
perhaps even longevity yeah
especially in terms of brain health it's
very inspiring to me because i've had
all sorts of foot problems and uh you
know just playing basketball for so many
years and just spraining both ankles
you know about half a dozen times and
just like i've had
you know i have orthotics from my
regular running shoes and then going
into the swim run shoes which are very
minimal even the salomons that i
typically run in
because the vivos are so hard for me to
deal with i'm wearing vivo everydays
right right yeah for this episode and i
have worn them but like if i wear them
too many hours
like i feel the this calf pain and i
feel my foot pain even more
but the solomons you know i had this one
of the reasons i actually stopped
running
the week before um april gave birth
because i'd had i had like this almost a
shin splint feeling that was starting to
happen
and so i had to stop and so i i mean i'm
definitely a
lead footer i mean i'm a thumper so um
you know just and there's this sense
that well that's just the way i am like
i have a heavy foot well that's not the
case
right that's just because this is the
way that your brain is wired to move
yourself in this way but that can be
retrained and
in addition to um you know what i
witnessed spending time with tony
i also reflect back upon my experience
doing the the
world championships yes and i was amazed
how many people were wearing vivos in
that ultra race
not everybody you know there was a there
was a variety of different kind of shoe
selections but
there was definitely a contingent of
competitors who were wearing view and i
was like
how are you going to do this race be
on your feet for nine hours or however
long this thing goes
on in this minimal barefoot shoe
like i couldn't wrap my head around it
and now i'm starting to understand that
not only is it possible like maybe it's
a better way to go
and i think to really you know punctuate
this whole thing and bring it back to
tony
he just completed last year
um he did this thing where he did the
the
he basically ran the entire length of
england like did the john o'groats run
like ultra running like you know
i don't know something like 40 or 50
miles a day remember that from one end
of the
you know the the island to the other it
was an incredible accomplishment
this year he just completed something
called three bear peaks where he ran
450 miles over nine days
it was like nine days seven hours 18
minutes
where he tackled the three tallest peaks
in the uk mount snowden in wales
scaffold peak in england and ben nevis
in scotland
when so there's a lot he ran between a
pavement in between these
in the these mountains right which he
ran in vivos
but then he would scale the mountains
barefoot or some combination of barefoot
and
wearing his vevos in addition to that
according to an article i just read
which i just found out i didn't know
this
apparently he had kovit like he was just
coming off having kovitz when he did
this
it must not have been a very severe case
of kovid
no kova just can't deal with tony like
tony yeah
well he's the natural lifestyle right
yeah kova is like i don't want to be in
tony right
tony's going to make me run barefoot
apparently this is a thing this race
and he broke the record for it i don't
know how many people have done it
um over the over the years but
essentially he was running uh
the equivalent of about two marathons
every day he's over
17 marathons total over this nine-day
period incredible yeah which is amazing
amazing
um and he's all about it's gonna this is
gonna dovetail into the into the
the big idea that we're gonna talk about
um this kind of like
ethos that he lives is all about trying
to align himself with the natural
rhythms of the planet like he's removed
all the chairs out of his house
and he's about squatting right being
barefoot and trying to connect with
something that is
very primal and ancestral about being
human
um which in many ways
as a result of you know the modernity of
the world in which we inhabit
we've lost connection with yeah i mean
and his and i think just one last
physiological question i mean i imagine
his feet are extremely muscular
i i met a guy in tahiti named mato
who is barefoot all the time and he once
sailed a canoe with like some other
tahitian guys
all the way to shanghai and uh then was
walking down the city streets of
shanghai barefoot and this guy doesn't
like his
feet are thick as
you know they just like muscle it's like
a pure muscle with toes coming out
and he everywhere he goes he can run on
any surface and
and hike any surface i mean i imagine
tony's feet have to be like that yeah
yeah well they don't look deformed or
anything like that i mean the original
impetus for him getting into this was
that he had some kind of foot deformity
and this was a means of trying to
correct that
um they don't look freakish but um
they have like the skin on the bottom is
much thicker obviously like he's not you
know like the tenderness
on the underside of most people's feet
my mine included and i'm sure yours
you know is so paper-thin and that gets
you know conditioned in a way where
you know he can run on loose tiny little
gravel rocks and it's not cutting
he doesn't feel it yeah amazing uh well
you had a couple of of
questions that we aren't going to tackle
later that um kind of
get into this fitness area one is a
woman
linda in marin who is trying to do the
same thing get into more functional body
strength and to age
great gracefully and kind of
transitioning out of mostly running
and endurance uh and she wondered if
there's anywhere to start like where
would you recommend somebody to follow
your lead how would you get how would
you recommend linda to start
there's a million videos on youtube you
can just
dial up functional fitness routines on
youtube and you'll
get tons of instructional videos
i wish i'd written this down but there's
one called like
mountain fitness or something like that
like they literally take every exercise
and make like a two minute video out of
it
whether it's a kettlebell exercise or
some kind of abdominal or back exercise
and they walk you through it so that you
can watch it and that's how i learned
how to do some really basic like
kettlebell
moves because that's really foreign to
me so
uh you know the perils of youtube which
we're gonna get into in a minute that's
a better transition
buffered by you know a lot of helpful
information when it comes to this kind
of stuff right
yes so i would start there i mean i
think the larger point
to her point about desiring to age
gracefully
is well considered because and we talked
about this last time as we get older
she's 53 i'm 53. i can continue
to advance my you know endurance
capacity that doesn't go away as we age
what becomes more difficult
is um maintaining strength and muscle
mass like that
starts to diminish as we get older and i
think
you know it's important to make sure
that you're
taking care of that um you know i've i
told you like oh i touch a weight and i
blow up and that's always been the case
for me
but i have noticed now at 53 it's taking
a little bit longer it's coming back
but i do have to be more patient with it
and i think
um you know i can five weeks into this
what do i have to say but i can tell you
that i feel better in my body and i feel
like i have more
control and agility and it's a good
feeling and i it's something that i'm
gonna
continue to do irrespective of you know
how much i
dip back into the endurance world and
you see it with
we mentioned this last time too like
this is the david goggins approach like
he's been just because he's running you
know 100 mile plus
runs doesn't mean that he's not in the
gym and you know he might be
a better ultra runner if he cut back on
that stuff
and lost 15 pounds of shoulder
shoulder mass right you know he might be
a better runner
but overall over the course of his life
will he be um
as strong and as fit and as healthy who
knows you know
right well i mean i'm sure he's been
told that a million times by people you
know you should what are you bench
pressing
for yeah yeah yeah but he's been in the
gym this entire time like he's like
it's it's two a days and three days um
every time and one of them is always in
the gym so
right um and functional stuff like often
bodyweight stuff
more than anything yeah you know like
pull-ups and push-ups right because the
gyms are closed
right you know there you go um all right
the big story
the big story do you want to you want to
kick this you brought this one up so
it's not going to be a surprise to
anybody who follows me on social media
because i've been posting about
yes but what i really want to do is
spend some time talking about this
documentary
the social dilemma which just premiered
on netflix
it's essentially an exploration
of the dangerous human impact of
social networking interspersed with
talking heads these tech experts who are
sounding the alarm on their own
creations and the
existential threat to humanity they pose
and i think what makes it
so compelling and distinct from other
kind of alarm bell documentaries
is that these talking heads are not only
alerting us to the dangers of what's
going on online right now they are the
architects
of it themselves right and they're
holding themselves to account on some
level
um that's you know a tangential uh
thread that we can pull on in a minute
because it's it's fraught with
complications yes but
i found this documentary to not only be
incredibly powerful
i really believe that it is the most
important
movie of the year and i can't stress
enough um
how how much i think everybody needs to
see this
film it is it is the um
revelation the neo revelation in the
matrix
you know it really is it's like we're
all neo and this is lawrence fishburne
uh coming to us to try to morpheus
trying to tell us
tell us what's really going on don't you
think i mean it not to be
not to make it like bigger than it is
but it is a really big issue and
morpheus is
tristan harris yeah and and that's
what's happening
yeah and he closes the movie by
essentially saying like how do you get
people to wake up from the matrix when
they don't even realize that they're in
the matrix
which is in the position of neo
when he comes to realize that there's
more going on than
he originally imagined and we and
to make it clear what's happening is
basically we're the product
you know i think uh you also sent me
this gq article
um that one of the people who's featured
in the movie geron lanier
um zack barron's gq profile of him and
in that uh jaren is basically quoted as
saying anytime you are provided with a
service like facebook for free
you are in fact the product being sold
and that's the point of this whole
documentary right we are the product we
are what's being mined
we are the precious metal you know
lifeblood of the earth that's being
mined
for money and we're doing it because we
think we're getting
better connection to our friends and
family but in reality
we're being teed up with content and
these news feeds
that might feel sometimes really good
but in the long run
are really bad for mental health uh
especially in young people
and are really really bad for social
uh welfare and democracy and it's
happening
to such an extent that we're completely
unaware that it's happening
and it is undermining our free will i
mean we can talk about whether we have
free will at all period but
certainly this is triggering us in a way
to
navigate the world from a perspective
where we think we're making decisions
about
the content that we consume but we've
been so manipulated by these platforms
that it leads us down these pathways and
introduces us to ideas that we didn't
consciously
choose for ourselves and i think jaron
lanier
is is like the godfather of this notion
like this guy is unbelievable right like
i would love to get him on the podcast i
mean he's been around forever he's
a pioneer virtual reality he you know
worked at atari for a long time he's
kind of this futurist philosopher king
many years ago he wrote his own
manifesto i mean we could talk about
tristan's manifesto but jaron's
you know he wrote like 10 reasons to
delete your social media like this is
not a new idea
no from his perspective he was recently
a guest on andrew yang's podcast which
everyone should check out
um super interesting
thoughtful uh you know perspective on
the impact of social media on
on on everybody but the movie is really
the brainchild of tristan harris who
has been making the podcast rounds for
many years
you know i would highly suggest checking
out his first appearance on sam harris's
podcast it was amazing
he's a former design ethicist from
google
and has kind of now stepped into this
role as you know the quote-unquote
conscience
of silicon valley he wrote this
manifesto when he was at google like hey
you know shouldn't we be thinking about
like the impact of these products and
how addictive they are like what are we
really doing here
i think we need to stop for a minute and
assess
the long-term implications of these
tools that we've crafted
and everybody seemed to agree it kind of
went viral within
not just google but silicon valley at
large everyone nodded
but then nothing happened and that led
him
to quit his job and create this now
nonprofit called the center for humane
technology which is really the one
organization i'm sure there's others but
the leading organization
that's trying to you know redress the
ills of
of these social platforms and these
technology behemoths and how they're
impacting
not just personal mental health
but how they're undermining the the
cohesion
and the social fabric of society at
large
so let's take let's kind of like unpack
it so we'll start with like
the human psychological component
because um
that's one thing that i think i didn't
fully get until watching this is the
idea is that
that they are the this ai
that is basically taking our data
analyzing the data and then using what
it's learned about us
to serve us more content in
in the idea to capture our attention to
mine our attention so they can sell this
stuff for pennies i mean it's pennies
a click like pennies so basically we're
being sold super cheap
yes you know but just a million times
over
but it is uh it's an understanding of
human psychology and twisting
it's like the greatest con ever it is
it's computer con
and it's understanding who we are and
what we want next before we even know we
want it
that's why it feels like free will when
we're clicking on something that's not
necessarily free will
right the way that they illustrate that
is with these little
uh dramatic interludes that they pepper
throughout the movie which
i will say if there's one flaw in this
movie i'm not so sure that these
these things are successful they do they
do one where they play out kind of a
family drama with actors and
you know the classic kind of trope of
being at the dinner table and like don't
have your phones and the teenagers are
rebelling and
that all feels kind of dated right now
but the other
little uh drama that they interpose
throughout
is this panel of uh
vincent kartheiser who you might know
from mad man
he plays the ai he plays three guys
or he plays all of them and they're all
sitting behind monitors
you know as puppeteers trying to you
know staring at their
product who is the young teen boy um
in the other drama trying to maintain
his connection to this platform like oh
he looks like he's going to log off send
him this so he stays here
right and it's sort of cheeky and fun
it's fun
but that's the point but the point the
larger point being like
all of these little bells and whistles
are
very well thought out and intended in
the same way a vegas can see
casino intends to keep you you know in
front of that slot machine or at the
table
right to keep you engaged on this
platform and not let you leave whether
it's
the color scheme or the way that every
time you refresh
it's a new feed all of these things are
a b
tested to the gills to maintain your
focus and keep those eyeballs
on that platform they serve you up the
ads you want to see
they you know know who the people are
that you really want to hear from on
these platforms and so we think we're
just staying in touch with our friends
when in reality we are being mined
for so much data that this ai
understands us better than we understand
ourselves and that's a frightening
prospect and how this gets played out
it's one thing to talk about it in kind
of an intellectual academic context but
we're seeing the deleterious
implications of this
getting played out in the fracturing of
our society and one of the quotes that
was really
impactful for me in watching this movie
was when
um somebody said i can't remember which
person said this maybe you'll remember
but he said
you know we we have this idea of the
truman show like yeah you're in a
reality show where you're being
manipulated
well imagine that everybody every single
person the billions of individuals that
are on facebook the 2.7 billion
truman shows right are all in their own
respective
personal truman show roger mcnamara said
that
everybody else yeah roger mcnamara and
when you realize that
you realize that we're not engaging in a
shared reality
we all have our own reality and we're
deluded to think that everyone is living
in our reality when in fact they are not
exactly so uh which
which means that you know the the time
magazine article that we both read this
week
which you're going to include in the
show notes which kind of um
it's from boots it's basically a
reporter that's been in kenosha
wisconsin
um uh in the post jacob blake
uh kind of protests and everything
that's been happening there she's there
you know smoke is cleared and she's
there and interviewing
uh which i think it was nine dozen or
seven dozen people
um about you know from all parts of you
know from the left to the right
about what they think about this
upcoming election and um
it's scary some of the views from both
sides that are that
that people were were uh you know just
basically parroting q anon theory and
and things like that and one point she
makes is you can't have a functional
democracy if you don't have an informed
public
and um it used to be a little easier to
figure out
uh or to figure out how to be informed
and now that's all very muddy
and the reason that's muddy and we can
talk about the you know fake news
traveling six times faster than real
news
on these platforms and that's one of the
reasons the other reason is that the ai
doesn't care what's fake or
or or real because it doesn't know
what's fake or real it just knows clicks
and and so some of the sometimes what
you're getting on your facebook feed
it won't necessarily feed you stuff you
like it won't necessarily feed you
material from people you like hearing
from
it will feed you stuff it knows you
don't like
because it knows it'll keep you on that
feed longer right so
you'll find if you wonder why there's
all this politics on your news feed
that's because it knows you don't like
it
and but you can't resist reading this
right if you click on it yeah
that's the paramount
connection that matters right right
there's a quote in that time article
by this woman whitney phillips who's a
professor at syracuse who studies online
disinformation and she said
they're not on the same she's talking
about these people who are kind of
canvassed who are all
like harboring you know ideas that range
from
insane conspiracy to you know
counter-cultural or what have you and
she said
they're not on the same epistemological
grounding they're not living in the same
worlds
you cannot have a functioning democracy
when people are not at the very least
occupying the same solar system and
this is what is so troubling and
problematic about all of this and i said
to you the other day when we were
talking about this
when we look at the very large
existential
problems that we face from climate
change to political division to
wild conspiracy theories to the
protesting in the streets
none of it can be properly addressed
and worked through if we're not
sharing some basic
set of facts we cannot solve
our problems existential and practical
if we don't solve this social dilemma
first
this is like the this is a root driver
of the division the divisiveness the
polarization
the anger the acrimony that we're
getting that we're seeing getting played
out on the streets all over the country
and i think we really need to
pause and reflect upon the role
that these technological behemoths play
in our society and i think it's
incumbent upon
us as the public to call for their
regulation you know this movie is very
dystopian when you watch it
and at the very end it's sort of like
okay well we can't leave the audience
just
feeling absolutely horrible without some
sense of hope or solution
but that kind of hopeful note that's
cast at the very end feels a little bit
tacked on there is a sense that well we
know we need to change like delete your
social media from your phone okay that's
one thing we can do
we need to regulate these companies okay
but what is the path
forward you know i have hope that
tristan
and his team at you know the center for
humane technology are
are they've got their eyeballs on this
and they're
they're coming up with these solutions
but
it's not like we have it all worked out
right now no i mean i think that there
are all right so let's let's pan one
thing you're talking about in the
dystopian
uh ending is uh you can cut from
all over the world you're seeing street
clashes
um and then the the guy who was
who went from facebook or yeah he was
like the facebook
uh guy who came up with the like button
no the guy that was
in charge of monetizing facebook that
went to pinterest oh right yeah yeah
he said uh they asked him what he most
worries about and he said in the
shortest time horizon
civil war and if that sounds extreme to
you
consider what um when you look back
and read about wars they start with
kindling
and it's like one little moment of
kindling that could spark it we've had
them
already we've had the kindling moments
i'm not trying to be alarmist but we
have had them you know we had
charlottesville
kenosha where where a 17 year old kid
goes around and is with a gun to try to
protect property i guess he thought he
was in the right
he ends up shooting and killing people
um and then
he's used as a pawn by right wing people
like tucker carlson and
and uh and ann coulter and donald trump
himself
um and and they don't care about this
kid you know like
it's it's it's a tragedy that a 17 year
old kid went and did that
for you know it's a tragedy for him and
and it's it's a tragedy for obviously
the people the families he affected
uh you know like we've had these
skirmishes
now so much we have in portland on the
we have
anarchists throwing molotov cocktails at
police officers
in compton we have people hunting cops
right i mean i'm not i'm not
picking sides here this is just what's
happening and so we have the kindling
the kindling is in place um i don't
think it's
our destiny is that but but certainly
you know if we if if it is we can look
back at now
as being as being where when it started
right um and if you look at
how twitter twitter's big moment was
the arab spring right when everyone's in
taiwan square in cairo
and and calling for the end of of the
yeah
murabak yeah yeah mubarak era
he'd been a dictator in egypt for you
know decades
and and they depose him and the same
thing happens it replicates across
uh um you know the arab world
and it becomes arab spring and if you
look at it now only tunisia has come out
of it
in a better place um libya is is
on the verge of even more civil war
looking like syria syria is
a shell of itself um isis came up
out of it and and how did isis
become so strong they recruited on
facebook
you know how did charlottesville uh
rally happen
they recruited on facebook so the social
media
can be beneficial but it's not in itself
beneficial
it's like this medium that it does tend
towards this topic even when things seem
to be going well
it can twist and turn on you um and so
that's i think what you're talking about
the dystopic ending right
um so how to how to fix it at the end of
this movie
um one way is to um bust these companies
up
you know yeah they need to be broken up
broken up we need to get
elizabeth warren you know either running
the
the justice department or the ftc
because she's on top of
the anti-competitive nature of
of these of these companies and there's
just no reason that they should be as
large and as powerful as they are
right like instagram came up
independently as facebook facebook
gobbled it up whatsapp came up
independently
it got gobbled up like certainly
whatsapp and instagram should be
separated and google and youtube
yeah google and youtube should be
separated yeah and
you know look there is something to be
said for like
these all these talking head these guys
are all became super successful
as a result of their involvement in tech
they're all worth tens if not hundreds
of millions of dollars
right because of their involvement in
this infrastructure
and a lot of uh how they learned how to
create these
persuasive technologies and these
these sort of you know the bells and
whistles get that get packed into this
they learned at stanford in bj fogg's
persuasive technology lab
bj fogg who's a master of behavior
change he's an amazing guy
i'm trying to get him on the podcast
we've been going back and forth
scheduling thing
but they took what they learned in his
lab
and then kind of weaponized it to create
this addictive
you know like call and response
relationship with the mobile apparatus
yeah it's um
and yes there's a certain amount of
guilt i think that some of these people
in the movie are must be feeling
um they didn't see it coming the guy
that created the like button
um what's his name you have him listed
here
justin rosenstein yeah he was like
we our whole goal was to spread love and
connection
they didn't see it coming right they
were playing chess and didn't realize it
um you know i'm not you know they they
didn't see it they're so smart but they
didn't see
this coming but you know maybe they
couldn't see it coming because they were
creating
something like the like button they
weren't you know it's like all the
different departments created this
greater computer mind um you know this
big brain like that gerund talks about
um and so they couldn't see it coming
and uh
and now that they do see it coming it's
it disturbs them and they're trying to
get people to
engage with the fact that this isn't
isn't healthy
um it's not it's not a partisan thing
no so in the in the drama around the
teenage boy you see him get
radicalized by way of youtube but
they they specifically you know create
some
you know uh fictional you know faction
you know that he gets radicalized into
because they don't this is not a
republican liberal thing trump makes no
appearance in this documentary
whatsoever
and the only politicians that kind of
offer sound bites are
marco rubio and jeff flake both
republicans who are sounding the alarm
for this being problematic
so this isn't a conservative liberal
thing
anybody should be well it shouldn't be
yeah everything gets weaponized and
everything
you know becomes politicized but in
truth anybody who's looking at this
clear-eyed
and objectively will understand that
this is a disease it's a pox
on our society and once we lose the
ability
to effectively and communicate with each
other
as tristan harris says it's checkmate on
humanity that's how big this
is yes civil war i don't think that's
overreaching no say that when you look
at what's happening right now we're
seeing
the early stages of what could become a
failed state definitely i mean
and i think what geron talks about is
like a place where we can't solve any of
the problems like you had mentioned
um because uh all we have is this
um contentious uh political arena and
authoritarians running everything and no
clear
idea of what to do and so you know that
that's what he
he's worried about a hundred years out
he is worried about our ability to solve
any problems whatsoever
um failed state absolutely is is
is something to be concerned about um
you also got to be concerned about the
kids i mean
uh we didn't get into what they talked
about that but they're talking about
spiking suicide rates of of girls
between 10 and 14 years old yeah
i mean 10 and 14 years old that's
usually there aren't
10 year olds don't do that 10 year olds
don't do that
you know and so uh obviously between 14
and 17 it's a spiked rate as well that's
something you maybe could
could understand why but between 10 and
14 so what we might feel is fomo
as adults um little kids are thinking of
i wish i
i wasn't me and this is the evidence why
so they're always seeing that evidence
of why they don't want to be themselves
yeah and and um and so yeah so it's it's
it's it's emergency time and zuckerberg
doesn't feel doesn't seem like the type
of guy that could fix it he has to be
imposed upon
well he i mean he's as feckless as ever
the talking
the sort of sound bites that they share
of him you're just like seriously like
you know he's not even
addressing this at all and what about
the google guys remember don't be evil
was their whole thing
i mean that that's gone you don't hear
that anymore like where are those guys
there's a fast company article that i'll
also link up in the show notes
uh that was published on 9 11 of this
year and the the headline is we can have
social media as we know it or we can
have democracy yeah that's how dire and
serious
this is it's as serious as a heart
attack and
you know it's it's terrifying and i
can't stop thinking about this movie
and i can't overstate how important i
think it is to
that everybody you know watch this and
have conversations about it at the same
time i would be
you know remiss and not calling out my
own duplicity here
you know you and i me too both i mean i
have an entire career because of social
media
there is some logic to this idea that it
is a tool and if used appropriately it
can it can be
beneficial for other people and for
ourselves it's given me
a career but one of the things that they
kind of dispel in a documentary is that
trope of
it's just a tool it's neutral right
right and you can you know you can
use it for good or you can use it for
evil and it kind of belies
it pulls the pulls covers on that trope
to say
it's not actually neutral but you know
yeah it's like
well i think this podcast is transmitted
over the internet
right people find out about it because
of social media well i have a facebook
account i have
i have an instagram account i post there
well but in podcasts new media in
general if you look at podcasts or any
sort of new media
and podcast being the most uh successful
form of new media i think that we've
ever seen you know blogs
couldn't touch what podcasts are doing
blogs are dead yeah blogs
and they never really you know it's just
another website but
what podcasts are doing uh financially
but also culturally
um it's a whole nother thing and that's
new media and one thing they
kind of this movie kind of looks at
steve jobs as this figure and as if
social media somehow twisted his dream
of the computer being the most important
tool for human evolution when in reality
steve jobs
parting shot was the iphone which is
probably the number one tool which gave
us podcasts and gave us social media to
this level the smartphone
um i don't think the hardware is uh
they got it you got to touch the
hardware too the hardware is the problem
too
you know when you can get notifications
and you can get this stuff right in your
pocket
um and that you can watch it right here
uh
you're never far from it i think that is
is uh
you also got to call out apple i mean
you know if you're going to call it
facebook and google and
everyone else instagram you can call out
apple too
um but you can also call ourselves out
right so like
we were we were talking about um yes you
you've got your whole career in this
podcast and here i am sitting here and
my biggest success
uh so far has been able to collaborate
with david on his book and
he is uh you know he he he he's not
famous from social media he's famous
from the podcast but that fueled his
social media which allowed the book to
become this mega hit and and gave
so there's things that come out of this
that are positive um but look at the way
david uses social media he uses it
it doesn't use him that's he follows the
difference right that's the difference
i don't even think does he even have an
iphone i don't even know i don't think
so no no
no his fiancee manages she does that
yeah yeah he doesn't like she'll shoot a
video of him and post it but he's not at
home
seeing who commented on his thing
and he's like the most inspirational
figure in the kind of
fitness you know self-improvement space
on the internet essentially yeah because
he he doesn't he's not a slave to
that stuff you know like like i i am
like i want to see who commented i care
about all that stuff
um but also you know you
i i'm not going to go as far as saying
there is no free will
like you can i go on youtube and i watch
the daily show and other late night
snippets on youtube and that's the only
thing i use it for
and i go in with a specific thing i want
to watch and i get the out and i
don't
watch their queued up videos so you can
use it as a tool you can but the the
larger thing is
just because you can doesn't mean it's
easy for everyone to do that
one comfort that i take because the
documentary
sort of uh establishes this idea that
these ais are all powerful like oh we
don't even know what they're doing and
they're controlling all of us and it's
now it's beyond our control this idea
that
you know we're gonna uh you know live in
this
uh you know kind of terminator world
where the computer's already where
they're like it's already happening
right right
but here's the thing yeah i ain't that
great
because like sometimes i'll watch a
youtube video because i want to see
like some knuckleheads say stupid thing
you know i was like oh let's see
let me see how bad this argument is and
then i get served up all these videos
as if like that's the person that i like
on it or i'll like
buy something like i bought a pair of
shoes from an ad that i saw
on instagram and then i get served up
more and more ads for that and it's like
well i just bought the thing i don't
need it anymore
like why are you doing so it's like it's
very rudimentary still
you're saying you're saying the good
news is tech doesn't work
well it's not tech often doesn't work
yeah yeah it's like it's hilarious like
if i
i'm like and i'll think like oh if i
watch this video then then i'm gonna get
all these suggested videos all of a
sudden and that happens every time
yeah so yeah just being like oh that's
why they're serving me up that video
because i clicked that other thing and
being aware of that
look you can delete your social media
apps off your phone
i go through periods of time where i do
that then they always find their way
back
yeah you can grayscale your phone you
can i mean one thing that i think is
is is really important is turning off
your notifications yeah you're not just
constantly inundated with bells and
whistles all day long
um that's a that's one way to take
greater control of your sanity
and i think just having conversations
about this stuff like you know as a
parent of
teenage girls i'm very connected to
the ills of you know what these
platforms are doing to young people
and when you layer the pandemic on top
of it
and now like the cree we didn't even
talk about the fact that california is
on fire right now and the sky's orange
you know all of this is contributing to
a very unhealthy state of mind in young
people
and it's really tragic and i'm seeing
kids cracking out there
like friends of friends who have teenage
kids
who are having a really hard time and
you know my family's not immune from
that
it's been really challenging and social
media
is not helping it's making it worse no
so just real quick um a couple of things
on uh their solutions one is breaking up
the big
tech the other is regulation what kind
of regulation one suggestion was a data
stream tax like the more data they take
from you the more tax they pay
the government um which would mean
which would limit like they basically be
more strategic about taking
and then there's a more radical version
of where if they take your data and they
earn money off it then you get money
yeah i mean it should be the default
shouldn't be that they
own the data right and you have to try
to get it back it should be that we own
our
our own data and we can make the choice
of whether we want to allow people
access to that or not and face australia
is phasing in a law that basically
facebook has to pay i think it's
australia has to pay
um the publishers if they if their
articles wind up on the platform right i
mean that's radical
and they're talking about closing that's
a major facebook talking about getting
out of
australia yeah because of that there's
no way they'll stand for that
but i think we need to see some
experimentation in this realm
i know that twitter is like beta testing
a subscription model like what if you
just had to pay 10 bucks a month to have
twitter
like i'd probably pay that to have
access to that platform
and they don't strip away all the other
like if you can create a different model
it's the ad model that's driving this
right so if we can
figure out we can pivot away towards a
healthier
um you know version that still
allows these people to like it's a it's
a capitalist enterprise
you know so i i don't begrudge that at
all but
not when it comes at the sacrifice of
human dignity and health and the
degradation of the social fabric of
our democratic principles absolutely i
think jack could be the guy that does
the most
uh experimenting and and gets it gets it
done quicker
um even though twitter is in some ways
the most problematic of these
because it's so polarized on twitter um
he also seems to be the one
trying to do the most um and you know
google seems
as bad as zuckerberg and facebook is
google seems completely out of touch
like google is not even trying to talk
about this
i mean at least zuckerberg realizes he
has to say something every once in a
while
like i don't hear from google ever on
youtube i mean to me
they are uh it's appalling what's
happening on youtube and
sundar just he i mean he seems like such
a nice guy
yeah like he's very polished and camera
ready
and he's very likeable but he's not
the face of the platform in the way that
jack is with twitter or mark is with
facebook
and facebook just feels irredeemable to
me
at this point it's it's it's um it's
crazy and then talking about the fires
here in an organ
in oregon there was rumors going on on
social media that antifa was starting
the fires in rural oregon which is like
trump country
and and like the fact that it's ever
even brought up while people are
running for their lives it's appalling
um and it just fuels my suspicion that
is the 2012 that they warned us about
like the quest
like you got to give it to the mayans
because a plus minus eight years
daniel pinchback kind of way yeah like
in the celestine prophecy kind of way
yeah yeah like 2012 was supposed to be
like the beginning where everything ends
or gets better um
and it's actually 2020 not 2012. and
it's
that buckminster fuller quote that uh
that i sent you that was in the movie
something about how like it's going to
be touch and go between you
dystopia and utopia with human with you
know we're either going to go from
oblivion or
between oblivion and utopia it's going
to be touch and go and we won't know
until like the last act what's going to
happen because these
obviously our technology trends towards
both
simultaneously and that's what we're
talking about here
uh but if we're going to get to utopia
um and
leave oblivion behind we have a lot of
work to do yeah
well it does feel like
an inflection point and i certainly can
see
that you know it could go either way and
it's up to us
it's up to us it's up to us and so if
there is a way
to leverage these platforms for good
certainly that's what i'm about but i
think it's incumbent upon all of us to
shoulder the responsibility of getting
active
having the conversations that need to be
had around
the health of these platforms and the
health of our families
because the stakes could not be higher
right now
and and activism when you come down to
it
is is just talking to people you know
it's it's you know activism
on a big on on the scale now it's all
online but it used to be phone banks and
knocking on doors and
for you it could be making some phone
calls i plan to
call people uh as the election closes in
and talk about this kind of stuff
voice to voice i'm going to take some
time and i'm going to call people
and that's the activism i'm going to do
around this and i'm going to implore
them
to uh think of love
first and and you know obviously i'm
going to advocate
for me that means voting for biden over
trump in in this thing but i also want
to talk about in general
youtube and find out where people are
getting their politics from you know
where they're gonna get there they're
getting their information from and have
that
greater um conversation as well and i
plan to do that
so uh that's what i'm going to do i
pledge to do that a pleasure to you guys
now and i will
follow through on that um and rich can
ask me how those conversations are going
but those are going to happen in my in
my world um
and i think the more conversations let's
using our phones to call people
and if you have to get a landline
because to me
that's my favorite tech it's my landline
i haven't had a landline in 20 years
it's the best piece of attack you got to
get a landline bro
it's the new it's that the new like
prepper thing like
having a landline are you telling me
jaren doesn't have a landline i'm sure
he does
right probably um meaningful
conversation matters now more than ever
and the truth is found in nuance
something i tweeted the other day
i think it's something we should all
take to heart uh all right let's take a
quick break and we'll be back with some
show and tell
and some wins of the week
and we're gonna take some listener
questions beautiful
all right and we're back i think that
went well adam i feel good today my
neurons are firing my whoop score is
through the roof my hearing variability
is good
bro your neurons are firing so hard i'm
ducking
yes you have to say that because you're
the co-host yeah that's right
i feel like a walking advertisement for
the podcast today i've got like my whoop
on
yeah i've got like this bottle that says
four sigmatic
on it i can smell the sweat sure you
know oh is that a track smith
um yeah like they're not a podcast
sponsor
yet but we're talking to them like i'd
love their stuff come on cool i'm
wearing my tenth
malcolm shirt malcolm malcolm's probably
wearing that same shirt right now i'm
sure he is
i think i saw him wearing this shirt in
an ad like well tracksmith's a really
cool brand they work with
malcolm uh knox robinson who's been on
the podcast
is collaborating with them on a few
things they're sponsoring mary kane
who you know was the woman that um
lindsey krauss wrote the article about
in the new york times about how she was
the fastest
runner but her career was sort of
decimated by alberto salazar and all
that so they're sponsoring her like
i don't know they make like really cool
stuff amazing like their ethos
how great is lindsay krauss can we just
say something she's the best i think
she's just one of them
i no but i i have emailed with her um
just a couple of times but i have not
met her but i
i find her reporting to be as good as it
gets yeah i love her
i loved having her on the podcast and
she's an
excellent twitter follow yeah yeah she's
fabulous
um what do we got all right well the
ethan hawk ted talk is out
yes it is give yourself permission
my favorite i love this ted talk i
shared this on social media back to the
social media but like
i love ethan hawk and i thought this ted
talk was so great
and it leveraged the best of what can be
done
in quarantine like he's not on the ted
stage he looks like he's in a country
western bar
in austin he's got he's he's got the
denim jacket like yeah
and he delivers this monologue that
makes it look like he's coming up with
it on the spot but clearly
like you know he's rehearsed this i like
moving the glasses and getting into it
so well
um i loved it i loved it i love and i
was like how can i get this guy in the
podcast who
i don't know ethan hawk i've never met
him i'm like i got to figure out a way
but he's had such an interesting career
path because he's also he's never just
pigeonholed himself he's always you know
he's written novels
i know um and now he's like taking on
kind of some self-help
uh you know the mcconaughey
universe well that's the thing are
actors the new self-help scions yeah i
don't know
he feels that way ethan hawk and matthew
mcconaughey have you talked about
matthew mcconaughey's no not yet but
before we do that
like ethan hawk just drops bombs on
creativity and it was so inspiring and
so beautifully
delivered in a way that you could um it
wasn't like here's the 10 things you
need to do like it was a
it was like a poetic monologue on
on you know the inherent creativity that
exists and lives within all of us
yearning to be expressed and you know i
just i just thought it was
beautiful and fun give yourself
permission to be creative yeah and
follow what you love
to figure out because you can he was
talking about his brother you can live
you can have a creative life and not
necessarily be
a creative you know artist or whatever
right
um you can you have a creative life and
just do the things you've loved and
and do them to the utmost um and that's
still a creative life
uh and he also but when he is talking
about kind of art
it's like don't don't worry if it's good
and that's like the hardest thing you
know i've been writing this novel
and it was like mid-second draft when
the baby came
and i'll get back to it soon but like uh
that's the hardest bit
is like and even just writing an article
the hardest bit is is this good
you know and and the less you think of
that the better and it's good you give
yourself permission to have it not be
good
you know like be you're playing the fool
it's a fool
it's kind of a fool's errand to try to
make a living as a creative person
anyway
it's like it was never a good career
choice like even back
before when like newspapers were in good
shape
and we didn't have all this kind of kind
of fractured attention and fractured
outlets
it still wasn't necessarily a smart move
to try to become
a writer or a painter or a standard
comic this outrageous
ego like oh the world needs to hear what
i have to say or are you kidding
me right
right now and he's like he's his point
is your voice matters all people trying
to become creative
matters but in in kind of a fly overview
none of it matters either
which is also kind of gives you
permission to be a fool because if it
doesn't matter who gives a
and and you're not going to be the one
to decide whether it matters anyway
you could never know what's going to
make something a success
it's like a secret sauce recipe that
nobody has the
it's a secret sauce no it has a recipe
for timing
matters so much and like you can't
control timing so
right um you know you can do the best do
it for the sake of doing it
because it is part and parcel of what
makes us human
and and you know he doesn't get into the
artist's way but you talk about the
artist's way the morning pages i mean
that's a great way to figure
out and just to be creative for yourself
you know yeah 100
yeah so are actors the new scions of
self-help yeah
adam skolnik are they i don't know it
feels that way
but it's not just ethan it's matt right
so he's
leading the charge leading the charge
the latest chapter
in the reconnaissance is this new book
that matthew has coming out
called uh green lights and it is
interesting when you kind of look at
matthew's career
how he's had these fits and starts and
then he was kind of a you know he he
kind of started off with the
you know the the the dazed and confused
era where
he you know carved out like a little
niche for himself and then
you know became a sort of cog in the
machine of studio rom-com land and
that played itself out and was never
really him and he had to find his way
back to
what his sweet spot is and he's just
blossomed into this
beautiful uh you know expression
of creative humanity really an actor the
latest
chapter of that are you know these
snippets like he only recently created
an
instagram account and he'll just like
drop pearls of wisdom and why i didn't
even know he had that oh yeah it's great
oh are you kidding it's like oh it's so
he's so
wise and soothing in his delivery i
don't know what it is specifically about
him but it's a guy who has
like sort of um you know
grabbed the horns of life and
created this you know path for himself
and there's something to be said for the
intentionality that he's brought to his
life in his career
that is super inspiring and the way that
he kind of conducts himself
is so welcoming and inviting it's like
if wooderson had a master's degree
in um psychology or something wooderson
from dazed and confused
it's like you know what i mean like the
wooderson whitterson himself
was his own prophet you know like the
idea yeah he was the pro
he was the prophet of that movie he was
he was the yoda
yeah he was like you just gotta you know
he's go with the flow kind of thing and
then like the you have the lincoln ads
you have the lincoln ads which are like
another kind of version of that
a more sophisticated version uh but the
reality of
of him is he does have his priorities
straight and
and um and so he is a guy to take advice
from i mean i think
you know both those guys are so it's
interesting though that they're staking
out that claim in that territory and
that is a function of
um new media isn't it like that where
where
you know there's a there's a place now
and it's not just them look at
lebron james and his voting stuff and
you know his promotion of social causes
or or whatever he wants to promote
um athletes do it and they've done it
for a long time
but it's kind of different for actors i
think to do it right yeah
it has to be the right one you know
who's also incredibly
inspirational online as an actor that
josh brolin really have you have you
ever gone to his instagram
no he is a poet really it's unbelievable
he writes these uh
posts that are just beautiful
really yeah and at first i i had no idea
okay that this guy had it in him check
it out
josh bro life is about to change matthew
mcconaughey
roland is is is real i mean it's very
um you know he'll just like tell these
stories
that are really about place and mood
they're not they're not trying to say
anything but
he is able to kind of evoke an emotional
response where
when you're reading what he's written
you feel like you're there
like it it it's he's very gifted in that
regard
all right so enter josh brolin into that
there you go
as well see yeah all right let's stop
let's stop what about
what are we doing now we're going to
talk about the videos
i got like i came a beautiful hollywood
star
yeah you leftist coastal elites you
fawning praises i don't want to follow
movie stars i don't want to fond these
movie stars
um so i just came straight from the
the gym right here by the way like some
people were
remember how i was like kind of wearing
a jacket and like presenting myself
in a nice way yes i do yes so some
people were like that's cool
some other people were like that doesn't
feel authentic you feel like you're
really
yeah some people were not happy with
that who are these people i don't know
who they are
they should be happy that today i'm
wearing shorts and i came straight from
the gym and i haven't taken a shower do
they care what you wear
i don't know um the vivo i got these
vivo barefoot shoes
vivo is not a sponsor of the podcast i
would like them to be they'd be great
um these are the ones that i've been
wearing and they're made out of recycled
materials which
which are great these are intended for
kind of trail running so there's some
like rivets on on the bottom here but
when you're they look
like they have more padding on them than
they do i assure you it's it's basically
just to
prevent you from cutting your feet up
like yeah no completely
no drop yeah it's flat there's no
padding whatsoever
it's like running in javian they're
comfortable and these are the only shoes
that i've that i've been wearing lately
um as i make this adjustment and i've
been seeing i thought you were running
barefoot
you know on running is a sponsor of the
show and they make amazing running shoes
so this isn't it's not an either or
thing um you know on
our very uh uh kind of revolutionary in
the traditional running space like what
they've done with their technology is
super interesting and i love their shoes
and their products
this is just an entirely different thing
that i'm trying to learn right now yeah
i've been having a lot of fun with it
you might go back and forth you just
want to
get your mechanics better even if you
put on running shoes i thought when you
there was a shot you put on social media
of you on the beach and i thought oh
maybe you're barefoot running on that
beach but i was actually okay yeah
yeah yeah so that on the yeah i can my
bare feet can handle the sand
yeah i'm just not ready for trail
running barefoot
like tony style so the vivo guys i met
them
in uh catalina at that swim run event
and uh they
told me to wear the everyday shoe
around for a while before you start
trying to run and like just do them 10
minutes at a time like you were saying
this is the everyday shoe i'm sorry it's
leather
it does look like leather how dare you
i'm sorry i didn't mean to bring this in
here
my vegan sensibility is offended i know
my son is probably sleeping on a leather
couch right now
i know you can't blame him though listen
vivo makes
recycled shoes which you should be all
over the recycle thing
knowing you i know well um
on that subject of recycled materials
should we check in on our 30-day
single-use plastic
challenge let's go what's going on so
how have you been doing with this
me i'm i'm changing diapers bro right
you've opted out you don't need another
challenge i'm out
i'm out i'm changing plastic diapers let
me preface
my answer here by saying that uh i
haven't done a great job like i think
what i said at the last when we when we
introduced this was that
i would post something on instagram and
try to enlist you know
everybody to do this with me and then i
didn't do it like i just
i didn't post anything on instagram
about it so um
that's my bad like i'm just you know i'm
trying not i'm trying to not be on
instagram all the time you know i'm
trying to be offline so
you know i just i forgot to do that and
didn't take the time to do that
but why can't a 30-day single-use
plastic challenge turn into a 60 day or
a 90 day
this is ongoing this shouldn't have a
sunset on it right this is about
changing habits
in terms of my own uh experience over
the last month
trying to do this i would give myself
like a b-minus or a c-plus
okay like i've done okay um
but i haven't knocked it out of the park
and
what it has done is exactly what i
mentioned last time which is
create a much more profound awareness
of how big this challenge is and how
difficult it is to do
i will say that i don't really buy stuff
so
yeah i'm not buying bottled water i'm
not buying things in the store that are
wrapped in plastic
but i'm also not doing most of the
shopping for
my home of six people right now you know
like julie's going to the grocery store
or
mathis is having food delivered you know
take out food i don't have control over
them so why you're getting a seat a
bunch of stuff
ends up at our house that's all plastic
and i'm like
julie you know i told her about this and
she's been trying to do her best as well
but
she's like look man i gotta get this
it's freaking hard
yeah you know and it's just appalling
when you look at the amount of garbage
that you know i've got six people in my
house
two older boys two girls we we've had
somebody stay with us for a little bit
last week in the teepee and that's a lot
of people
and it's really disturbing how much
refuse we produce and this experience
has made me
more mindful and pay more attention to
the choices that i'm making
it's engendered a greater appreciation
for how difficult
it is to make this switch you know i
don't have
uh lauren i think her name's lauren
singer for tossers
i have a lauren singer store down the
street from me where i can bring my
glass thing and get it filled up
no so but you know what we can do is we
can enlist the whole family in this
cause
and everyone can be part of this that's
how that's how you're gonna get from c
plus to a yeah well it's tough you know
like i feel my my daughter
is not interested you know what i mean
how do you get her on board
she's in that phase of like i'm not
interested in anything my parents are
interested in
right right has a point of you know just
making a point for yourself and trying
to
disassociate not disassociate but like
differentiate her life from her she's
punk rock
and my 13 year old the same they're
trying to figure out who they are
yeah and they can only do that when
they're in contra position to
who we are so i'm okay with that
it's an expensive exploratory period
yeah
but it's very difficult for me to get
her
on board with something like this right
so she's not plant-based you know
she is she's plant-based but like she'll
order
uh you know she'll like get
uh beyond burger from carl's jr you know
it's like she's
that's where she's at right now i love
her
and listen you know i don't want to talk
about like it's like my
my daughters particularly are at an age
right now where
you know they didn't sign up to be
talked about on a podcast where hundreds
of thousands of people are listening to
it
and so you know when they were younger
it's one thing and now it's like they
have their own lives and they're
entitled to their privacy
oh yeah i get it i'm not putting my
son's face on any uh social media
at all right yeah so i get it um
but the challenge continues the
challenge continues if i find myself on
instagram
i will try to post something so we can
have a conversation about you know what
we could do
here's the thing i forgot marcus and
anna full time yeah before i forget
i believe that i said i was gonna give
away a bunch of stuff
yes yeah so we're gonna have to revisit
that next time all right we're gonna we
will do that but
we have to be able to solicit
everybody's stories
from our experiences we're gonna realign
we're gonna we're gonna
so this whole thing went under um but we
got to get marcus erickson and anna
cummins in on this the five gyres the
people that started five gyres marcus
is they both have great stories you know
we gotta
we'll talk about this i don't know so
they started five gyres they're early in
on plastic pollution they're like
they were anna was talking about plastic
bag bans 20 years ago
um and marcus and anna have a non-profit
called five gyres which is
uh all about researching um and creating
citizen science
around the plastic marine plastic
pollution problem um
marcus once built a boat out of uh
plastic water bottles and sailed it to
the uh pacific garbage patch outside
hawaii
um he's paddled the mississippi river
that's different from
david david rothschild in his plastic
plastic different but around the same
time they were both doing that
um but what marcus has done is made it
his entire life
which is going to all the different
gyres um
trawling for plastic particles what is a
gyre a gyre are these currents like the
great current systems in the oceans
there's five of them and so the north
pacific south pacific north atlantic
south atlantic and then the indian ocean
and they all have these current systems
that that
that bring water into the center of
these oceans and then spin it back out
and so what ends up happening is a lot
of the plastic trash
gets swirled into these gyres and broken
down into into particles
and so when he went out to the great
pacific garbage patch which he'd heard
about
it sounded like a big landfill in the
middle of the ocean but in reality it's
a lot of water and just
like tiny particles there are some big
stuff but it's very rare it's like a
gelatinous
soupy yeah it's almost like plankton
it's it's like i remember being
when i went with the five joshua
expedition in the north atlantic
um we would trawl in the bluest water
you could ever have ever seen
you know blue so blue so clear
and we'd still come up with these
plastic
particles that were like look
plankton-sized and so
uh they created this organization they
they have ambassadors that go and talk
about plastic pollution
there are they advocate for yes we can
all reduce our plastic
reliance in single-use plastic but also
solutions are
upstream we need to stop plastic plants
from being built
we need to create past laws to make it
illegal to have plastic bags
you know plastic bottle bands single-use
plastic bands
that's kind of their focus because you
can't fix it on an individual basis
in time um the idea is that this
these particles are everywhere now
they're in the arctic ice cores we've
talked about this before
so um you know we are the plastic age
uh and anyway they're great we got to
get them on this
on podcast yeah that's cool i would love
to do that i mean there are some
things that are happening right now
technologically it seems
on a surface level that creating an
analog to plastic that is biodegradable
and dissolves in water shouldn't be that
difficult
you think you think but a lot of that a
lot of that stuff that says compostable
it's only compostable if the recycling
center that your stuff goes
to has the machine to break it down and
almost none of them do
so the the smoothie place that has the
compostable thing it's not the type of
thing you put it in the landfill
dissolves to soil
no it needs to be heated in a specific
way
and they really aren't that they really
aren't
depressing to hear yeah so just so you
know so it's always better to bring your
own
bottle like you have your water bottle
just bring that it's always better to
bring your own
right that's the key yeah sometimes they
won't fill it though
in the age of the kovitz sometimes yeah
yeah
the other thing that's you go to
starbucks complicated this stuff
not that i go to starbucks that often my
daughters like it
and um you bring your own thing and they
won't fill it and then they're like
well they'll pour it in a plastic cup
and then you can pour that plastic cup
into your thing and then that plastic
cup gets thrown out it's like well that
defeats the whole purpose of the
thing well that's been happening so like
that that's that's a lot that's
that's that's pre-covered you sometimes
run into that but now it's probably even
more so
um yeah it's um let's move on let's get
to the wins man
we need some wins we need some wins you
go you're you got
the dystopia so um
first win of the week here is uh the
triple
uh to the back to swim run we can't get
away from
the greatest sport in the history of
mankind i know
um it's the greatest actually by the way
i got an email
or a dm notification from from michael
uh from otillo they just put out
a video that's like a retrospective on
the
history of swim their race series and
they kind of go through the origins and
through
over the years and clips from all the
races when it started and
everyone was had backpacks on and all
that kind of stuff
uh and i made i have like a cameo like a
couple of comments from interviews in
there yeah
you should link up that video it's cool
then for people that are new to this and
they don't even know what we're talking
about it gives you a retrospective i
love it this
board i haven't seen it beautiful cool
in any event because the swim run races
are like all races are getting canceled
although i think they did do
end again didn't they conduct a race
they did end again and then they did
the utila final 15 which is always an
option of the regular
world championship weekend but this time
it was the only thing available right
but the world championship race
not happened was canceled cancelled so
they did the final 15k event the
the world champion of the whole thing
yes
um decided to uh instead
because of this race getting cancelled
to do
to swim run the entire stockholm
archipelago
yes which is insanely huge anybody who's
been there
knows it's like there's thousands of
islands in this archipelago
uh and it involved 80 col an 80
kilometer eight doing 80 kilometers a
day of swimming and running
uh the world championship race is 75
kilometers more so like doing
is 260 kilometers all together all
together yeah so 80 a day but they did
three so it was three days started
friday at like four in the morning
and you talked to these guys so bro i
did before they left george
uh i'm gonna mispronounce him uh giacomo
giacomo bajacomo
yeah so what he told me was that there
is a lot of
uh there are maps and charts that they
can use to create their route
for the second day because the second
day was basically the
the world championship course right and
the third day is closer to stockholm and
it's
and and they're swimming in a shipping
channel part of the time
right and uh and so they that that and
people have been to those islands
but there are islands that they nobody
had even really been to
um in the top part so where they started
at oklahoma
like way out on the outer rim way out
and so they didn't go to every island
but they um they did go to 90 islands
wow over the course of these three days
and it was how many of them did it i
think it was six
and four of them were dude the whole
thing and the other
team was going to switch off uh swimming
and running legs
and they only had one boat that was
their whole support was one boat
so they would like all their food and
everything was in that boat
so when they when they left on their
swim run leg they had to bring whatever
food
and nutrition they were going to use on
that run part also and then get back in
the water get back to the boat
and so they couldn't really separate
they had to kind of stay together and
hang together because their only support
was one boat and especially at the end
when they're going through the
shipping channel you have to have a boat
you know you can't you can't be
out there on your own no one see you and
so uh
yeah so i'm looking at what they told me
90 islands 210
k of trail running 50k of open water
swimming in three days
i mean that is beast that's a lot that's
a lot dude
a lot in rough waters and and you know i
saw some of the
the instagram story clips like it was
the weather
didn't look so great yeah it got away it
got cold so they had
they had to move it up i think they were
going to do it at another time but then
and then the weather started to turn to
fall
and fall in scandinavia small
scandinavia is not like
fall in southern california
no and and the shipping like the exposed
swims where you're in these shipping
lanes it's not just that it's dangerous
because of boats it's that
with that exposure you get like high
seas
conditions right yeah in the world
championship course like that's
the the choppiest and the most
tumultuous of the waters because you
you're not getting the wind breaks from
having the islands
you know yeah preventing the that kind
of chop
it does look like there was a lot of
glassy um seas
and certainly in the early stages i mean
it looks beautiful right i mean
i'm so impressed with them no it was
eight it's pretty cool
it looks like eight so did they cancel
eight did they before
did they where did they sleep and stuff
so i think at night they
they found it in like the first you know
they got to the
they got to an inn i think they slept
the night in in and then they started
and then they got to an end for the
second
they slept in inside got it yeah yeah
cool
yeah all right well good on them
congrats that's awesome
keeping the flame alive on swim run when
there's no organized races
uh tony riddles three bear peaks was
another win of the week for me but we
already
we already talked about that and you
have one more yeah uh maya gabera the
brazilian big wave surfer
uh surfed a 73 and a half foot wave at
nazareth
it was uh the biggest wave ever surfed
by a woman
and it was the biggest wave surfed by
anybody
in the winter season 2019 2020 which is
big wave surfing
dan that's their danica patrick moment
basically that's amazing it's amazing
maya uh surfed this wave in february
um but it was only this week was when
the world surf league released
that it was as big as as that uh
basically what happens with big wave
surfing is
every may um people submit
photos and videos and and they try to
decide which they have the big wave
awards
and they try to decide who's who's got
the best ride of the year who's got the
biggest wave of the
year and and so on and uh this year
there was no big wave
banquet because obviously uh covid and
so they've been
releasing these awards piecemeal on zoom
sessions that are broadcast
by the surf league um and you know we
already knew kai lenny had the big wave
of the year for the men and
ride of the year and uh was all that but
uh the women's were they were waiting
because uh maya gabera and then a french
woman named justine dupont
um also surfed a massive wave at that
same
toeing compen competition where kai said
he said his mark at nazareth
70-foot wave it was the nazareth where
maya set her
uh 73.5 and basically they couldn't
decide
like the committee couldn't decide who
had the bigger way between maya and
justine
and so they brought in uh wave engineers
from kelly slater's waveco that have you
know surf rain
surf ranch they brought in
oceanographers from scripps
they brought in aerospace engineers from
usc
and together how did they make that
decision they looked at the cameras
that were taken and the angles and the
amount of light in the sky
and the tide tables and they and they
looked at the imagery
and the stuff in the image images and
they tried to
determine uh based on all of that who
had the biggest wave
and um maya was surfing in the men's
competition
she was teaming up with a male surfer
from germany named sebastian stuttner
who's i think he did
he clearly surfed a huge wave too i
believe there was a video of him
that was circulated pretty that was i
think in 2019 no i'm like i'm talking
about like a week or two a week ago
yeah he's he's a beast i mean that guy
the wave
the waves uh there can be so big and the
wind can be so heavy that
um there are basically four foot waves
on the big
80 foot waves you know like that so they
have to ride these heavy boards
in order to stay upright on these
massive mountains of water and the
reason that the waves are so big there
real quickly i'm there's a story i wrote
for the new york times that'll be out uh
when this is out it'll it comes out
wednesday we're recording it on monday
we release on thursday so it'll be out
there and we can put it in the
show notes um but there's an offshore
canyon that's deeper than the grand
canyon
that can capture some of the swell that
comes in and it speeds it up and then it
bends it northwest and so when there's
also a southwest swell in at the same
time
those two swells meet and there's a
magnification effect and amplification
so typically a 15 foot swell
can be a 30-foot wave if it hits a reef
right in this case a 15-foot swell can
be a 70-foot wave
because the canyon all of a sudden it
butts a 40-foot sand bar
and so that vertic verticality plus
these two swells and that sped
up swell and the bending of it converges
and it creates this incredible
wave that crashes on the cliffs right
you know where there's a lighthouse and
a fort and it's yeah
you always know nazareth because you see
that lighthouse yeah in the foreign and
that
there's something about that camera
angle
that gives you like it creates a
dramatic perspective because you see
that
that um tower yeah in the foreground on
the left-hand side
always it makes the wave look bigger so
when you say
maya surfed a 73 and a half foot wave
when i'm thinking of the videos that
i've seen of people surfing nazareth
they look like they're well over 100
feet
right so when garrett mcnamara was like
the first guy to
surf nazare and so what happened with i
i talked to
to garrett for this story and so i've
tried to we've we've gone back and forth
about getting him on the podcast too
he's a hell of a storyteller he's great
yeah
yeah so he basically said that in 2005
he's he was he came up
in the 90s in in um
he's old guard so he was when larry
hamilton was was inventing toe and
surfing he was
he was there in the early gen and then
around
um you know the in the middle 2000s late
2000s tone surfing became passe
kind of like the big wave guys were like
it's not cool it's cooler to paddle in
why do you need this gas guzzler
it's not the purest you know the sports
purists were kind of turning the nose up
at it
but garrett wanted to surf a hundred
foot wave so he never did
and so in 2005 some bodyboarder from
portugal
who lived there um sent him an email
saying you got to check out this wave
and he didn't even get it it was like
floating in his archives until his wife
found
it in 2010 and so he got it he's like
okay let's go check it out so he went
over there
he teamed up with a surfer from england
called named andrew cotton
and the two of them created this they
decided to try to surf it and so in 2011
i think he surfed a 78-foot wave there
that
was went all over the news went viral i
remember that that one was estimated to
be over a hundred feet at the time now
it's considered 78 feet
this is what you measure from the back
you measure from the trough
of the wave and then you just measure it
up to the very tip of the lip of the
wave
um it's just because the reason people
thought was over 100 is because what
you're talking about that angle from
above
will always make it look bigger so the
angle the camera angles
kind of gave it this distorted view that
was over 100 feet
but so far nobody on paper has surfed a
100 foot wave there
80 foot is the men's record um in 2011
he surfed it
still there was a lot of most surfers
were saying oh it's a it's a messy wave
it's just a slope it's not like
jaws or mavericks this like people just
poo-pooed
how hard it is to surf there and how
dangerous it is
i mean it's literally like a skyscraper
is about to fall on you
who knows i'm not i'm not sure why
people would poo poo it to me
but you know we're not big wave surfers
so exactly you know whatever
but um he would kept trying to convince
people to come surf there and in 2013
sebastian stuttner showed up maya gabera
showed up
maya had a very famous accent there and
she almost died she was pulled from the
water unconscious she was given cpr to
to be resuscitated she ended up breaking
her fibula
um herniating a disc it required
multiple back surgery spinal fusion
surgeries in the aftermath of that
accident she was hated on by
big wave legends who are basically
saying you know you were
irresponsible and you put people in
danger and blah blah
well in 2018 she set the woman's mark
for for
riding a 68-foot wave and put that in
the guinness book of records for the
first time
and now she's surfed a 73.5 foot wave
breaking her own record and i'd never
heard of her yeah until now and uh and
she lives there
in nazareth full-time she's a great
interview
it was an honor to do the story justine
upton turned out her wave was 70 feet
kai's was 70 feet so maya for the first
time has created this
like i said the danica patrick moment uh
woman actually
uh having the biggest wave of the year
nice yeah
pretty incredible hats off to maya yeah
chapel
um so that'll be in the new york times
on tuesday
wednesday wednesday wednesday the 16th
page
yeah should lead this you should see
epic photos epic photos and some video
cool yeah all right man yeah awesome
well let's do some listener questions
let's do it hey rich hey adam my name is
mark i'm from germany
i'm a nutritionist an athlete an
environmentalist and of course
100 plant-based or inspired by your
podcast rich
my question has to do with the climate
emergency we find ourselves
in i already imposed a lot of
restrictions upon myself
like choosing my bike to set up my car
reducing the amount of plastic i buy
increases the amount of local and
seasonal fruits and vegetables
not taking planes and many things more
and these restrictions have actually
improved my quality of life especially
the plastic diet
however i'm also struggling to choose
between what is unnecessary and should
thus be restricted
and what is still acceptable like using
the car for holiday
creating carbon missions by watching
netflix or living in a
beautiful but huge house instead of a
more minimalistic and
environmentally friendly alternatives
i'm trying to figure out the right spot
between tom hanks and cast away and see
another dicaprio in the wolf of wall
street
thanks guys and you can use it on air um
thank you for the question mark that's a
great question
it sounds like he's he's more tom hanks
and castaway than he is leonardo
dicaprio and
wolf of wall street yes by a country
mile
um this is the dilemma that we're all
struggling with is it not and i think
there are things that we can do
which you are already doing and i
applaud you for that
and i'm trying to do the same
at the same time i think we need to like
acknowledge and just recognize
that that none of us are are living you
know a completely carbon neutral
lifestyle like we are consumptive beings
living in the material world on planet
earth
we have an aspiration to live more
gently
on the planet to live more in alignment
with the rhythms
of what serves the ecosystem that we all
share
but none of us are immune from the harms
that just our existence
creates and i don't think that
anybody is served by
somebody becoming you know a complete
martyr
or a recluse i think that we do what we
can
and we always strive to be better if we
can you know
the more carbon neutral we can become
the less that we get on airplanes the
less
uh you know um petrochemicals that we're
using all of these things are
are great but i think where we have to
think about how can we
leverage this message to create a ripple
effect with other people
right so if everybody reduced their
carbon footprint 10 percent that would
be
massive and more impactful than you
living in you know an electric van down
by the river and never communicating
with anyone you know what i mean
so it goes back to
what we were talking about at the outset
of this podcast which is that meaningful
conversation matters so i think
where you can create leverage
is to engage your community with these
ideas to try to spread them
and what i found and everybody has their
own personal
strategy for how they communicate and
share ideas
i found that that what seems to work
really well
is to make these lifestyle choices seem
fun and cool like they're not the
purview
of an antiquated class of people that
you can't connect with but they're
actually
awesome you know and and we can thrive
and live and be happy and fulfilled and
connected
in a way that perhaps eludes us in our
modern world by
adopting some of these habits and
practices so
i think it's i think that the evolution
for you
is not to you know become tom hanks and
castaway
but to try to be uh you know a
lighthouse and to be an example
of some of these lifestyle principles um
within your community because we live in
the world
right you're not you're not a monk
meditating in the cave
right you're a spiritual being having a
human experience
in the midst of a lot of chaos and
disruption
so how can you be
a force for positive change among those
people that you're connected with
i like that i mean i think uh first of
all
it's very funny and witty ending to the
question um
but i'm pretty sure that tom hanks
didn't want to be the guy in castaway
i remember that movie
but yeah i mean i think um we make
choices to live our lives because we
like you know like the fact that you've
had positive
reinforcement from the lifestyle choices
you've made
um shows that it you did it for you as
well as for any any other reason
you know you yes you're limiting your
emissions you're limiting your impact
and that's a great thing but that's a
great thing for you as well as for
the world and that's great i mean that's
i think that's the ideal right
that you that that's the kind of balance
that we want to strike where we're
feeling like we're living our truth and
we're feeling good living our truth and
we're actually feeling better than we
did when we weren't
and some of it is like so-called
restrictions have actually ended up
being
beneficial to us personally i think
that's great i think it's amazing that
you've done that
um and uh but i agree i think there's
also
fixes you can do if you if you live in a
regular house i mean there's a lot
between
living in a tiny home and a big house
and if you do own your own home uh you
could
install gray water systems cistern to
capture rain
you can you can model some environmental
technologies that could be then used
widespread in your neighborhood or your
town
i think there's things you can do that
could then those kinds of modalities
that can be replicated to really fix
cities and systemic problems um that's
another
way of going if you are going to choose
to live kind of the house you have now
100 percent and so i think that they're
you know you can just keep going with
this
but you don't have to live in a certain
type of way you know you don't have to
live in a tiny place
to have a big impact right and it
shouldn't be driven by
guilt but rather you know this this
aspiration to live more connected
yeah and you can be minimalist i mean i
i don't live
i don't have a big footprint uh in terms
of where i live but
um but some of that is is just kind of
the circumstances that you know
of of my life so uh and there's ways to
uh correct me if i'm wrong you probably
know more about this and i probably
should know more about this than i do
but when you are um
uh traveling by air you can you can
purchase carbon carbon success
or you can find a way to do that travel
in a carbon neutral way you can
you can do carbon offsets or how do we
do that do you know about that
that would be something to you know i i
can because i love travel
right you know and i i feel guilty when
i get on a plane of course
i don't buy carbon offsets for my plane
rides but i do know somebody that does
um or you could be like greta and just
see if you can hitch a ride on a nice
sailboat by the way she's got that
documentary coming out soon oh really
yeah
she was sharing about that the other day
um did we answer
mark's question i feel i feel like you
did all right thank you mark
all right moving on let's hear from josh
hey rich and adam this is josh from
right outside dc uh i just wanted to say
i love you guys we're able to
kind of go between the format and the
interview segments kudos to pulling it
off my question is more of an ask for
advice
i'm a few months away from 30 years old
i've been successful in the traditional
sense of monetary
relationship career progression making
my way up the corporate ladder at a
fortune 500 company
and probably a lot faster than i ever
could have imagined but i can already
see
my mindset and the leadership style
doesn't quite match up with that of my
soon-to-be peers
um a piece of dan buettner in july
emphasized
um kind of how i'm feeling i'm a rebel
at heart
so i'm comfortable with pressing on the
edge of the status quo
but i worry it might be the universe
telling me
my purpose may lie somewhere else i know
you've
both kind of successfully transferred
from corporate styles the more
independent channels
and i was wondering if you were sitting
in my chair what would you do
all right thanks guys bye and of course
this is great to put on air thanks
thank you josh that's a great question
uh first of all
congrats on being successful
on the cusp of becoming 30 years old
moving up the ladder certainly something
to be proud of to be
you know really stable and to have a
future
ahead of you and um that's no small
thing and you know i i think there's
this
this like sensibility right now like
everybody needs to quit their job and
like you know go on these vision quests
and
we've lost sight of just valuing you
know the product of
like hard work and making your way in
the world like that's fantastic so
first of all you should be proud of what
you've created for yourself and you
should feel guilty about that
um i'm not surprised that you have a
little tickle in the back of your mind
saying maybe this isn't my
ultimate purpose in life um if you found
your purpose
in that fortune 500 company then more
power to you that's fantastic
but if you think maybe there's something
else that
might you know provide your life with a
little bit more meaning and
and purpose outside of the context of
your career
my suggestion to you would be to
continue to fertilize and and foster
that instinct you know you may not know
exactly what it is right now it sounds
like it's pretty vague
at the moment um that understanding i
think is powerful
it doesn't mean that you need to do
anything different than what you're
doing right now stay at your job
it seems like it's serving you well in
the meantime
knowing that perhaps there might be
something else you might want to do
later
just means that you should be more
mindful about your consumptive habits
like try to live
lean like don't go out and you know
lease
you know the the bmw because your peers
who are in your income bracket who are
sitting in the office right next to you
are doing that like don't
get caught up in the keeping up with the
jones's game that happens
with the ascension up the corporate
ladder i saw myself do it when i was
doing the same thing at a law firm when
my peers would get to a certain point i
felt like
i have to upgrade here and i have to
upgrade there and i was quickly
you know living outside of my means and
this is a moment in which you should be
you know banking that cash so that you
have choices
and freedom so that when that impulse
matures to the point where you have
clarity around what
might give your life greater meaning
outside of your job you have the
flexibility
the freedom and the opportunity to take
advantage of that the thing you don't
want to have happen
is the creation of the kind of gilded
prison
that happens to so many people and it
happens imperceptibly
very slowly over time like well i'm
making good money and i'm moving up and
i'm going to get that promotion and that
bonus so i can
not only afford this car but that new
couch and i'm gonna you know move from
this apartment to the next one
it's a very gradual process like the
frog you know
slowly boiling in the in in the water
it's not until it's too late that you
realize like you're stuck
now i'm married and i have kids and i've
got a mortgage and right
that thing that i wanted to do it's just
not possible so i guess it will happen
in the next life like you don't want to
be
that guy so live lean
live minimally save your money
you know continue to show up for your
job learn as much as you can
you know create a network of people meet
as many people as you can
and uh and and understand that
look you're 29 you've got your whole
life ahead of you yep
this is not you know a foregone
conclusion that you have to stay at this
job you have tons of opportunities
that will be available to you throughout
your life like i just
a couple years ago i wrote this tweet
about how i thought my life was over at
30 like you're
you've got compared to where i was at 30
it's ridiculous like you're
doing great um i was in a very different
state at age 30 and yet here i am at 53
with this
completely unique life that i never
would have thought possible and i wrote
this tweet about how
you know basically you know just keep
showing up for life and anything is
possible and that
freaking tweet like will not die like it
continues to get shared and just today
upworthy posted it on their instagram
page so like a million and a half people
so like my phone blew up
and it's it's intended to mean like
listen
you know if you think you're stuck in
life or on a certain path you can always
reinvent yourself
you can always do that you want to make
responsible decisions so that
reinvention
process can be less painful than it
needs to be
but don't think that just because you're
30 and at a fortune 500 company that
your life is already scripted out
right certainly is not one reason i
think that
that tweet that i wrote still has life
is that you know people are like oh it
inspires me and makes me feel like i
you know i still can make these choices
and these course corrections in my life
but i think it also makes people feel
better about the fact that they haven't
done anything yeah
like oh i'm 40 like look he didn't do
this until he was 50 so i still have
time you know that's
not what i'm saying what i'm saying is
you know
life is about constant reinvention we
tend to think of it as static i'm here
and this is who i am
and this is what my life is and will
always will always be and that
is not the case you always have the
power and the domain and the control
to make changes in your life just make
sure that you're
doing what you need to do now so that
that doesn't have to be
problematic that you're not stuck and
you don't want to be that guy with
regrets he's like oh if i had done this
differently then i could have
you know become a scuba instructor in in
aruba or whatever it is that you know
your heart is yearning for
yeah man that's well said i think uh
setting yourself up for flexibility so
you could be responsive to
and move and and do what you need to do
without
be nimble yeah not not to wait back
i will correct you one thing i was never
i was never on any corporate ladder
um i was working in the nonprofit world
and then never really made any money
which made it easier in some ways to
then
leap and still not make any money yeah
you didn't have the ability to create
the gilded cage
i didn't have the cage i didn't have a
lot um
a lot of bills so um but i've certainly
also
lived in there where i had a lot of
bills and was trying to figure it out
too at the same time mid-career
so you know i think the idea of of
saving money is good
um i think i agree that doesn't sound
like you know exactly which direction to
go into yet or maybe you do you just
didn't say
in which case uh fertilizing that might
mean
following that intuition the things that
you love you follow what ethan hawk was
saying
follow what you love to do what is it
you love to do and
figure out and figure that out and if
you know what that is and you spend more
time doing that
you're kind of fertilizing and watering
that i think you can find some pathways
um towards a new life there i do think
it sounds like you already know
that you don't want to stay at the
fortune 500 company forever
that you're seeing wait i could go this
far and i i'm seeing the people that are
the senior
positions in that company and you're
seeing yourself and you're like wait i'm
not really
that's not necessarily me and that's
cool that's fine it doesn't mean you
have to quit right now
it just means that um you've gotten a
viewpoint
and i would i would trust that sounds
like it's an instinct to trust to me
um and it sounds like you've if you've
been successful at this place you can be
successful in anything
and i think you know that part of the
celebration of the
entrepreneur that's very much a part of
our culture
packed into this kind of hustle you know
24 7 sensibility
is you know there's a there's an idea
with all of that that is
to say if you're not um founding your
startup
if you're not like following your
passion 24 7
that that you know your life doesn't
have value or that you've missed the
point or something like that and i think
that that pendulum
you know needs to swing back a little
bit to say hey
you at the fortune 500 company you know
you're doing good
like that's you know you should you
shouldn't feel like if you're not like
in silicon valley you know creating the
next whatever
that what you're doing isn't you know of
equal value
no i don't think we're saying that but
what we're saying is if you're not
fulfilled in your job
and you haven't built the the you don't
have the payments and all that
then you still are versatile yeah you
can go anywhere
but if you are considering between
staying at the fortune 500 company
and creating the app that's going to
save the world and
dot and becoming a dive instructor in
the caribbean
please become a dive instructor in the
caribbean i will say that
what what if he could invent the app
that saves the world
no don't do that no no no because that
won't won't work that way we already we
already know
from this movie that that goes sideways
on us please don't create nap
what about the app that tells you about
the
sustainability factor of your consumer
purchases remember when we were talking
about that no no
i remember reading someone tweeted uh
that
she and her husband want to start a uh
venture capital firm to pay people not
to do podcasts
because everyone has a podcast
you have to pay me a lot of money you
can you can keep podcasting you're good
at it right
just nobody knew no more no more
possibilities too many podcasts
all right let's let's let's let's round
this out let's round this out one more
question from canada
hi rich and adam my name is victoria
asikis i'm calling from ottawa ontario
canada and you can absolutely play this
on the air
i love the podcast and do thank you both
for your work and wisdom
my question is with respect to working
from home and still trying to navigate
your career as a young professional
for some background i'm 31 years old and
a business lawyer
i always used to think of myself as an
introvert who craved working from home
all the time especially when it wasn't
an option pre-covered
fast forward to this now mid-covered
time and i'm finding myself
really struggling especially as a young
lawyer with working from home for what
is soon to be half a year
i never appreciated before the
importance of collaboration with
colleagues
meeting clients for lunch creating
long-standing relationships both in the
workplace and outside the work
environment
and the true importance of establishing
these relationships especially
relatively early in my career
no matter what point you're at in your
life career-wise we are constantly
reminded of the importance of networking
building a book of business getting out
there and meeting people
the problem is this has now been
completely turned on its head we can't
have these social interactions
we can't meet people to build business
and we can't truly have those
professional experiences
where these relationships can thrive my
question is
how do you think the corporate client
relationship will change going forward
as a young professional what do you
think i and others like me
should be doing now to try and salvage
some of these relationships
while also trying to establish new ones
when we can't do it face-to-face in the
manner that we've been taught
thank you i really hope you consider my
question and as someone from canada i've
got to throw in a go raptors
all right victoria thank you for the
question it's a great question i mean i
first i would say
that i'm with you 110 on
this idea of being an introvert i
thought i've been training for this my
whole life this is not going to be a
problem like this is my default setting
anyway
and i've really met my maker with that
and you know i vacillate between moments
of
despair and melancholy with the um
the social isolation of it all you know
we're not we're not hardwired to be
separate and it has its challenges for
everybody and there's a spectrum
some people are having a harder time of
it than others of course
but um i'm sympathetic to the toll that
it's having on on
all of us not being able to function and
be in the world
um in a way that we're meant to be
you know i think the first thing i would
say is that
there is a sense you know the part of
where you're coming from
feels like you feel like you're the only
one in this predicament but this
predicament
is something we're all contending with
what you're struggling with
is the exact same thing that every
single person
not only in your field but all across
the world is dealing with
and just today there was a news thing
that popped up
that i saw that you know there's there's
a good chance that
we won't have a safe vaccine until like
and that's a possibility that we have to
um
factor into this there may not be a
short term
i mean we're already seven months into
this thing short term what does that
even mean anymore
there may not be a short-term resolution
to this that's going to get us back
into the world in the way that we would
prefer so with that
how do we move forward professionally
in terms of how we approach our career
and how we build a book of business and
how we interface with the world
and we're left with no choice
but to take advantage of these digital
platforms
back to digital platforms again in order
to do this i think
one thing i can say um
from experience as somebody who's worked
from home for many years at this point
and prior to that did work in an office
as a lawyer
that it's important that you
take control of your daily schedule
otherwise it will control you
so you have to set in place
a structure that's conducive not only to
your
productivity but also to your happiness
i think the idea initially of just being
in your pajamas all day and sitting on
the couch with the tv on in the
background as you're typing away on your
laptop
might seem appealing but we've been at
this long enough now
where most people are realizing that
that's actually making them unhappy
and i think you need to be regimented
diligent and mindful about what your
schedule is so you get up in the morning
as if you're going to commute to your
office and you mimic some version of
that in your house you should have
a morning routine and you should have
clear boundaries
that differentiate the work day from the
rest of your day
so that you're creating some
structures and a sense of stability and
healthy boundaries around your
profession so it doesn't bleed into
everything and i think
most people are just learning this now
and
when you don't have those things in
place then everything becomes like a
drab
gray like you're kind of always working
but not really working
you're not as productive as you could be
or should be
even though you seem to have more hours
during the day because you're not
commuting and all of these things
contribute
to this soupy mess of disaffectation
i found in my own experience so uh you
know getting up making your bed putting
on the clothes that you would wear to
work or
you know doing your meditation doing
your journaling taking breaks to go
outside to have an exercise regimen all
of these things are crucial
in terms of the professional aspect of
your question how do you build a book a
business how do you remain connected
with these people look it's going to
have to be on zoom
the only other thing you can do is to
try to engage with people in your
locality from
from you know a perspective of doing it
you know with social distancing like hey
we can meet outdoors at this cafe and
sit
six feet apart right and have a business
meeting i mean we're seeing this
happening in los
angeles i don't know what it's like in
ottawa right now i suspect because
better
canadian it's much better than it is
here um but
you know there is some flexibility with
travel
and physical presence with other
individuals and if you're wearing masks
and you're
outdoors and you're separated or what
you know there are ways of doing this
that are uh you know not as risky
that don't mean that you have to be
staring at a screen all day long
you can also be like adam and get a
landline and call people up on the phone
not everything needs to be
on zoom right and
you know making sure that you're staying
in in touch with friends and family and
doing all of that just for your own
personal
uh you know well-being but on the
professional tip
look there are very like that we're
going to go back to the social platforms
like
linkedin is actually an incredible
resource for making contacts
for developing those contacts for you
know trying to
you know cultivate new business on the
client
front right now that's just the way the
world
is so um you know
suffering is a result of uh suffering is
a
is a is directly correlated to the
extent to which we
we resist what is resistance so you can
either
resist what's happening right now which
is that we're all in our houses
and you can develop a resentment about
that and
be a victim and say well if i wasn't at
home then i could be going and
developing all of this business and i
could be much more successful than i
am or you can accept what is happening
and educate yourself about how to use
these very powerful tools
to innovate in your career in a new
and interesting way when everyone's
zagging how can you zig
always looking for the opportunity the
hidden opportunity
in what everyone is perceiving as a
crisis right
what is the one thing that no one else
is doing that you could do
that could give you an advantage in
terms of how you're building your
network and your relationships that will
fuel and underscore your book of
business and put you in good stead with
your employer
that's awesome really well said i'll
just highlight a couple things you
already mentioned
and a couple of them are number one
make sure you have that exercise routine
you have that you're taking care of
yourself
outside of the workplace and you have
that getting outside
running cycling whatever it is hiking
walking whatever you like to do
swimming make sure that's that's locked
into your program
because that'll alleviate some of this
stress and it'll get you outside because
it sounds like you're just kind of going
a little stir crazy which i get i
understand that
um b uh i would say you know the
interesting thing about covet is it
gives us an opportunity to press pause a
little bit you know that's
one of the power of pressing pause of
like you know all of a sudden the sky is
clear and the traffic you know we can't
say that now because of the fires but
you know what i mean like there was a
pressing pause aspect of kovid that was
really nice
and i would say that um
you know don't function from a pre-covid
playbook now
like yes you want to advance your career
yes it will happen on its own it's
probably happening now without you even
noticing it
um but don't expect necessarily to
have you know picked up this client or
that client as easily as you might have
before and don't beat yourself up for it
right
you know you're functioning within this
new sphere you're accepting what is and
so part of that is
um don't necessarily put yourself under
so much pressure
like maybe you might have as a type a
person
in a different type of environment right
you know you don't want to give yourself
you don't want to put that kind of
pressure on yourself also
you have a job yeah a lot of people
don't right
yeah yeah so focus on gratitude yeah and
then
ultimately um you we are all going to
come out of this
and at some point this period that seems
like
you're running in place and kind of
languishing in this middle part of your
career
or you know not making necessarily
getting the terrain that you're covering
the train you wish you had at 31
at some point you're going to be 35 36
presumably in the same
same career and you're going to have
this incredible experience of what it
was like
to be a business attorney in the worst
climate for business in the history of
that of our lifetimes and you're going
to have all this
all this uh information that you'll be
able to impart on other clients and it's
going to be a wealth of information it's
going to be very positive for you in the
future
so just getting through this period
staying employed still working
and then figuring out how to help your
clients within this climate
all that is going to pay off for you
even if you can't see how right now
yeah that's a very good point there's a
an adage in the recovery community
which goes like this i wonder what that
would have been like had i been
truly sober right and that is to say
that when you're weathering a difficult
situation whether it's like the death of
a relative
or a divorce or you know some kind of
difficult
emotionally trying situation
you want to be your best self you want
to be your most
emotionally mentally spiritually fit
it's not just about not doing drugs or
or drinking
it's about emotional sobriety right
[Music]
because you don't want to look back on
that experience a year later and think
i wonder what how i would have conducted
myself had i really been dialed in
you know what i mean you want to look
back and go you know what like i did the
work and i was able to show up 100
and be of service and do it with grace
and gratitude
and that's the stuff of esteem building
right to look back on that and go you
know what that was really hard but i was
available for all of it and i got
through it and i feel
more empowered as a result of that and
more resilient and
able to handle whatever life can throw
at me
and one day we'll all grow up and tell
our grandkids really boring coveted
survival stories
right what's going to really be
interesting is
how the younger generation not only gets
through this but
the stories that they will tell their
kids and their grandkids because
this is very formative that's going to
be the real baby boom
right not the during kovid but post kobu
when everyone could go party again
yeah there's plenty of people partying
now
that's true i forgot so all right
we're gonna avoid you know pulling on
that thread and we're gonna put a pin on
it
until next time thank you my friend how
do you feel i feel good this was good i
thought
this was good i'm not even tired yet but
i feel like it's coming it's like it's
like
nibbling at my system right yeah you're
gonna go home and crash
i better not i have to i think it's it's
baby time when i get it you gotta take
those
cat naps whenever you can man exactly if
you wanna come over to my house and
grab a snooze in the teepee hey that
sounds good available
thanks man um good man all right well
hopefully we're back in two weeks again
yep until then you can follow adam at
adam skolnik on the social medias that
you're trying to avoid and that you're
taking off your phone right now
because you just watched that movie uh
if you want your
message considered for an upcoming
episode
of the roll-on edition of the podcast
leave us
one at four two three five four six two
six
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button on youtube on apple and on
spotify
check the show notes on the episode page
at richroll.com we'll put links up to
everything we talked about today
you can also submit your questions on
the facebook group appreciate the love
you guys
see you back here in a couple days with
another episode that i really want to
tell you it is but i'm not going to
you're just going to have to wait that's
the way it is because i'm making the
rules because it's my podcast
your podcast peace plants
[Music]
you